Lul, was ist hier los?
Ich habe gerade gesehen, in der Viewerliste
campen schon die ersten Leute
auf dem Channel.
Ja, Camper,
ihr seid entlarvt.
Easy.
Ja, da ist der nächste Camper
hier.
Skriks Inc.
Channel Campsor.
Ich muss
ein bisschen Technik
zu euch kaufen. Vor allem muss ich mir
Ich habe mir nämlich was Neues
bestellt bei Unity Media.
Erstmal
warten.
Erstmal warten, bis Twitch sich eingekriegt hat
und
gesagt hat, dass der Stream on ist.
Moin. Wen haben wir da? Den Impuls
Future und den Phoenix.
Underscore. Ganz wichtig.
Pfeifhead.
Pfeifhead Username.
Ich habe gerade
dein Kot-Video gesehen. Mal wieder mega nice und klasse,
dass du wieder Videos
machst. Ja, ich weiß auch nicht, warum ich
auf einmal so motiviert bin. Ich hatte heute
die Auswahl.
Ich hatte heute die Auswahl,
ein Video zu machen, zu einem Comment, was wir
vielleicht uns heute angucken.
Oder
mal zwischendurch mal wieder gestreamt.
Also ich muss ja auch ab und zu mal
streben. Ist der Tracker schon fertig?
Nee, der ist noch nicht ganz fertig, aber ich habe schon ein paar
Neues. Der hat jetzt E-Mail-Tracking.
Kann ich nachher mal zeigen, den Tracksor?
Erinnere mich bitte nochmal dran. Ich bin mir nicht mehr sicher,
weil ich bin vergesslich, was sowas angeht.
Genau, und
da muss ich mal wieder streben so inzwischen durch,
weil wir haben neue Emotes, Leute. Wir haben neue
Emotes. Wir haben jetzt, ich zeige
es euch mal. Wir haben
WubLull. Das haben wir schon
die ganze Zeit. Wir haben
WubS. Das ist, wenn
mal wieder irgendwas nicht funktioniert, wie es sollte.
Wir haben Cup in HD.
Und ganz wichtig,
ich bin mittlerweile 35,
wir haben WubOld.
Also wir haben neue Comments am Start.
Hat ein bisschen gedauert, bis
sie genehmigt wurden. Ich meine, es war Wochenende.
Twitch arbeitet auch nicht unbedingt immer
rund um die Uhr. Ja, und wo
bin ich jetzt stehen geblieben? Genau, ich dachte mir, ich mache
einfach mal wieder eine Runde stream dazwischen, ja.
Es reicht, wenn ich alle zwei
Tage ein Video mache, wenn überhaupt. Also weil ich meine,
sonst ist, je nachdem, sonst ist meine
Motivation wieder vielleicht schneller weg,
wenn ich es gar so sehr übertreibe. Deswegen machen wir
es erstmal langsam. Übrigens, ne,
es ist, das muss ich jetzt auch mal sagen,
es ist übelst frustrierend, wenn
man anfängt,
auf YouTube nach
längerer Zeit wieder Videos zu machen.
Sag ich aber gleich was zu, weil ich habe mir
überlegt, ich poste, ich poste den
Stream heute mal auf YouTube.
Ich warte jetzt aber erstmal, bis Twitch die Ankündigung geschickt hat.
Das ist...
Ja, da wird es, da wird es ein bisschen voll.
Aber es passt, es ist unter der Woche, da wird es wahrscheinlich nicht so
voll. Genau, und zwar, was ich euch
zeigen wollte, ich habe, ich habe
bei Unity Media, ich habe mir was Neues bestellt.
Wir haben es uns ja mal vor einer Weile angeguckt.
Ich habe ja die ganze Zeit, hatte ich,
ja, Telekom plus Unity Media parallel,
weil ich dem einen
nicht getraut habe und dem anderen nicht getraut habe.
Um ehrlich zu sein, ich traue der ganzen Geschichte immer noch nicht.
Aber,
ich traue meinem Geldbeutel, ich habe keinen Bock,
zwei Internetanschlüsse zu bezahlen. Ich habe keinen Bock,
140 Euro auszugeben im Monat.
Muss ich mal überlegen, 140 Euro für Internet
in Deutschland, Alter.
Nicht nice, so, das sagt.
Das ist eher...
Und
deswegen habe ich die Telekom jetzt gekündigt.
Hat den Grund,
ähm, ich
will halt
den, den Anbieter, der bei mir die höhere
Bandbreite liefert, bei mir am Standort.
Und
der, der alles irgendwie anbieten kann,
Unity Media, kann, halt
der ganze, der ganze Fernsehkram, ich meine,
ich brauche ihn nicht, aber da gibt es Leute, die wollen Fernsehen gucken.
Und, ähm,
ich will halt
40 Mbit ab und 400 down.
Ich hätte die Auswahl bei der Telekom gehabt,
maximal 250
down und dafür 100 ab.
Allerdings, wohlgemerkt,
bräuchte ich dann zusätzlich immer noch
einen Unity Media Gedöns für Fernsehen.
Oder, oder aber,
ich müsste mir eine Satellitenschüssel hinstellen.
Ist auch nicht so sinnvoll, ne.
Ja, und
letztendlich
bin ich jetzt bei Unity Media gelandet
wieder. Hatte ich die ganze Zeit schon.
Den Ausschlag, der ausschlaggebende Punkt
war, und ich weiß, das ist überall in Deutschland
unterschiedlich,
der Ausschlaggebende Punkt
ist gewesen, dass
die Telekom bei mir nicht sonderlich stabil war.
Ich weiß, bei den meisten Leuten ist es genau umgedreht.
Bei den meisten Leuten ist die Telekom
stabiler als Unity Media, aber
bei mir ist es umgedreht. Bei mir hat die Telekom übelste Probleme.
Und deswegen gibt es jetzt Unity Media.
Easy.
Und deswegen muss ich mir
zumindest eine neue Fritzbox holen, weil
die, die ich jetzt habe, ich habe aktuell
eine 3740 ist das, glaube ich.
Zeig mal her.
Ja, die billigste habe ich.
Die ist halt,
die hat nur einen 100 Mbit-Port.
Muss ich das mal überlegen. Im Jahr 2018
oder 2017, wo ich die gekauft habe,
gibt es tatsächlich von AVM
noch Router,
wie die Cisco-Fans sagen, Routers
mit einem 100 Mbit-Port.
Hyperlull ist das.
Geil, warum es sowas gibt.
War nicht der Sibaro?
Also auf jeden Fall, Leute,
bevor
ich das auf YouTube poste heute,
hallo Michael,
bevor ich das auf YouTube poste,
wir brauchen einen Mod.
Es muss mindestens ein Mod da sein.
Wenn kein Mod da ist, kann ich
nicht auf YouTube posten, weil
man weiß nie so genau, was da von YouTube
auftaucht alles.
Das ist nicht so ganz klar im Vorfeld.
9DVCS
F
Chat for Mod.
Ja, das ist zwar QChat,
allerdings
brauche ich da lieber meinen Mods,
die schon eine Weile dabei sind,
als im Chat das zu moderieren.
Im Discord gucken, ob da irgendwie der Sibaro
oder so am Start ist.
Ist die Musik zu laut?
Nö, passt eigentlich, denke ich.
Alter, was ist hier gespammt?
Was ist hier los?
Ich habe letztens in den Comments gelesen,
die Leute haben sich alle wahnsinnig gewundert,
ob ich einen Discord habe.
Also, wenn ihr einen Discord,
und ich habe noch einen Discord, wollt,
dann schreibt es in die Kommentare.
Oh, ich habe das Fenster nicht ausgeblendet.
Dankeschön.
So.
Der Sibaro ist nicht da.
Doch, der Sibaro ist da.
Ja, da ist er.
Gibt es ja nicht.
Hat das Discord gecheckt?
Ja, Discord hat es kapiert.
Okay, immerhin.
Ja, Twitch Prime.
Ach, ich habe ja ganz vergessen,
ich habe ja sogar extra einen Prime Sound.
Prime.
Mike, MZR und Twitch Prime.
Nice, dankeschön.
Huge.
Nice.
Na gut.
Ja, und Discord wieder aus.
Also, was ich heute vorhabe,
ist, ich will mal ausprobieren,
ob das Ganze funktioniert,
weil, nachdem ich jetzt ja ausnahmsweise
mal wieder furchtbar aktiv auf YouTube gewesen bin,
ob YouTube-only-Leute das mit einer Einblendung,
keine Ahnung.
Aber das ist nice.
Das ist gut, also...
Diejenige, die das nicht oder,
die nicht mit dem Internet umgekehrt hat,
noodle ich mit.
Wie sagt der?
Ich habe das jetzt nicht verstanden.
Ja, gut.
Also, das geht.
Ich weiß nicht, wie ich das machen soll.
Ich habe es mir mal gekauft.
Und jetzt habe ich es dir gesagt.
Ich weiß nicht, wie ich es machen soll,
ich weiß es nicht,
aber das mache ich jetzt.
Ich hoffe, die Motivation verlässt mich nicht.
Ach, wisst ihr was?
Ich poste das jetzt mal auf YouTube.
Mal gucken, was passiert.
Gucken ohne Mod.
Im Zweifelsfall muss ich entweder gleich jemanden modden.
Oder, was habe ich denn hier am zweiten Bildschirm jetzt für ein Mist aufgemacht?
Oder ich ban einfach alle, die mir auf den Sack gehen.
Das geht natürlich auch.
Und ihr wisst, wir gehen Menschen prinzipiell auf den Keks.
Okay.
Ach gut, ein Sibaro ist da.
Pock.
Also Sibaro, ich werde jetzt mal auf YouTube posten, dass ich online bin mit einem Stremsor.
Und dass wir uns heute ein bisschen die YouTube-Comments angucken.
Weil es waren richtig viele nice, gute Comments dabei.
Es waren auch viele, muss ich jetzt mal sagen.
Es waren auch die übertriebenen Call of Duty Fanboy-Kommentare wieder dabei.
Und eins habe ich gemerkt.
Sonntag Upload.
Sonntag 18 Uhr.
18 Uhr 20 oder wann das ongegangen ist.
Ich weiß gar nicht, sieht man das überhaupt, wann das Video ongegangen ist?
Kann man das irgendwo, wenn man nicht eingeloggt ist?
Ne, na, sieht man, sieht man nicht.
Ist auf jeden Fall zu spät.
Weil die Leute können nicht mehr gucken sonntags.
Und montags sind die Leute arbeiten.
Sind es einfach mal 20% weniger Views innerhalb der ersten paar Stunden wie auf den anderen.
So, ich poste das jetzt mal.
Mal gucken, ich bin echt gespannt, was passiert.
Kann man überhaupt Twitch?
Kann man überhaupt Twitch veröffentlichen?
Kann man überhaupt eine Linkung auf YouTube posten, ohne, ohne dass Instant MonkaTos angesagt ist?
Probieren wir mal aus.
Ich bin ja nicht der Einzige, der das macht, ja.
Außerdem habe ich vor ein, zwei Jahren auch die Overwatch-Streams gepostet.
Habe ich das ja auch gepostet.
Twitch.tv, Wopelords.
By the way, gibt neue Emotes.
Genau.
Oh, ich habe zu viel Text geschrieben.
Da steht dann alles unter mehr Anzeigen.
Das, das, das sackt.
Okay, Beitrag erstellen. Achtung, Leute.
Jetzt kommen...
Jetzt kommen die YouTube-Leute.
Irgendwie ist die YouTube-Seite ganz schön kaputt in letzter Zeit.
Oh, leider kann ich es euch nicht zeigen, ne?
Leider kann ich es euch nicht zeigen.
Mittlerweile ist es auf YouTube wirklich, ähm...
Ja, MonkaSmoke, das ist so kaputt.
Ups.
Ursprünglich, also vor...
Keine Ahnung, wann war das? 2010?
Also, es hat sich über die Jahre immer verschlimmert.
Und zwar, am Anfang war das so, du hattest hier oben dein Creator-Center gehabt auf YouTube.
Und da hattest du alles drin.
Eine Inbox mit Chat-Nachrichten, Kommentare, Monetarisierung für Videos, Videolisten, alles.
Und mittlerweile...
Ich weiß nicht, inwieweit man da reinguckt, wenn man keine Videos macht.
Aber mittlerweile ist es so auf YouTube, du hast fünf verschiedene UIs, wo du Sachen einstellst.
Du hast das neue Creator-Studio Beta.
Da steht ganz fett Beta drauf, aber du wirst standardmäßig drauf geleitet.
In dem du noch nicht mal so basic Sachen wie Playlists machen kannst.
Willst du Playlists machen, musst du ins Creator-Studio.
Musst du ins Creator-Studio Classic.
Willst du Einblendungen im Video machen, musst du auf den Cards-Editor.
Willst du Sachen editieren im Video, kriegst du den Video-Editor.
Total weird, du hast fünf verschiedene UIs.
Channel bearbeiten geht nochmal im komplett anderen Menü und sowas.
Ganz, ganz weird, ganz, ganz weird.
Felix, zwei Monate, dankeschön.
Moin, schwarz auf weiß.
Ist Unity Media gut? Wollen von Telekom zu Unity Media wechseln.
Es kommt drauf an, wo du wohnst, ja.
Wie sieht es denn bei dir aus?
Also ich meine, wenn Telekom und Unity Media ähnliche Sachen anbieten, würde ich sagen, pauschal würde ich die Telekom bevorzugen.
Außer bei mir, wo es die Telekom nicht gebacken kriegt, eine ordentlich stabile Sache zu liefern.
Wenn du allerdings bei einem der beiden Anbieter mehr kriegst und der Preis für dich angemessen erscheint, dann würde ich auch sagen, nimm den.
Ich weiß, ist schwierig, ja.
Was hast du denn zur Auswahl?
Ja, previously, das neue Creator Studio ist übelst, übelst crap.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was sie sich dabei gedacht haben.
Vor allem, dass das YouTube Creator Studio, das steht schon seit einem Jahr auf Beta, ne.
Seit einem Jahr steht das auf Beta und es kommt einfach nicht mehr rein.
Wo ich mir denke, was, was, was machen die da eigentlich?
Omega level.
Aber es ist halt, es ist halt YouTube.
Oder wie der Master Craber immer sagt, YouTubee.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man auf die Aussprache kommt, aber wenn der Carsten das sagt, dann ist das so.
Oink, Killer, Tomate.
Die Telekom hat es nicht geschissen, bekommen bei euch drei Monate Gutschrift.
Die Telekom bekommt vieles nicht geschissen.
Die Unity Media bekommt auch vieles nicht geschissen.
Zumindest, was ich mir jetzt bestellt habe bei Unity Media, ist das da.
2Fly.
Das können, ganz ehrlich, 2Fly, könnte auch irgendwie der Name von irgendeinem schlechten Hip-Hop-Match sein.
Klingt irgendwie ein bisschen so.
Oder 3Fly.
Und, oh, jetzt kommt es.
3Fly.
Richtig, jetzt kommen die Leute hier aber an.
Moin an alle, die von YouTube am Start sind.
Wo ist der Minecraft-Staubsauger?
Ja, also.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, wie gut das funktioniert.
Ich muss jetzt erstmal meinen USB-Stick an dem Staubsauger zum Laufen kriegen,
dass ich überhaupt was drauf installieren kann, weil der Staubsauger...
Ich könnte.
Auch für die Leute, die von YouTube kommen,
den könnte ich nochmal meinen Staubsauger zeigen.
Zumindest das Problem ist, ich habe da glaube ich nur 2 GB Platzcekler.
Das ist ein bisschen schwierig alles, ne?
Auf dem Staubsauger.
Äh, was sagt ihr?
Kann man sich Modern Warfare vorbestellen?
Ich würde mir aus Prinzip nie was vorbestellen.
Weil man muss sich immer...
Was hast du davon, wenn du es vorbestellst?
Oder haben die irgendwelche super...
Ähm, zeig mal das Ubuntu-Scheißhaus.
Es gibt nur ein Ubuntu-Staubsauger.
Es gibt kein Ubuntu-Klo.
Das Klo ist auch ohne Ubuntu schlau genug.
Ähm, was versprichst du dir denn vom Vorbestellen?
So, ähm...
Genau, was ich mir jetzt bestellt habe bei Unity Media ist folgendes.
Ich habe mir hier 2Play Fly 400 bestellt.
Ich habe mir nur aus dem einzigen Grund 2Play bestellt,
weil es billiger ist als einfach nur Internet mit Kabelanschluss.
Dass es auch nichts schnelleres gibt.
Und man muss hier ganz genau gucken.
Man muss hier nämlich ganz genau gucken,
weil das da ist das Wichtige.
Das muss man dazu bestellen.
Sonst ist es Crap, wenn man das nicht dabei bestellt.
Und damit bekommt man dann 400 MB Down
und mit Power Upload für 2,99 Euro.
Euro im Monat mehr, kriegt man 40 MB Upload.
Friseur auch auf Twitch, ja?
Mach mal Ausrufezeichen Frisi.
Er heißt ja nicht mal Friseur, er heißt ja Frisi mittlerweile.
Oder der High-Society-Frizz-Meister.
Alter, Sibaro.
Auf Megalolex.
Genau, Ausrufezeichen Frisi.
Ist der Bot kaputt?
Ist der Nightbot kaputt?
Ne, der Nightbot ist da.
Ausrufezeichen Fabian.
Haben wir nicht Ausrufezeichen Frisi drin?
Hm.
Onkasmum.
Naja, also das muss ich mal schauen.
Und deswegen muss ich mir eine neue Fritzbox bestellen.
Die alte muss ich leider wegschmeißen.
Wisst ihr eigentlich, was das für ein Akt war?
Das Ding am Laufen zu kriegen?
Hinter dem Unity-Media-Router?
Moin.
Oh, ich muss meinen Chatlogger anmachen.
Wenn ich meinen Chatlogger nicht anmache,
übersehe ich tausende Fragen jetzt wieder.
Nein, Leute.
Ich muss den Chatlogger einschalten.
Keylogger.
Ist an.
Also.
Wer jetzt im Chat schreibt.
Wer jetzt aus Versehen sein Passwort...
Warum nicht, Mario?
Wer jetzt aus Versehen sein Passwort im Chat postet,
hat gelitten.
Oh.
Oh!
Schon wieder abgelaufen.
Ich dachte, ich hab erst...
Wie nennen wir es denn?
Ich hab erst die...
Evaluierungszeit...
Neu evaluiert.
Aber das Passwort von euch, das glaube ich euch nicht.
Das ist zu komplex.
Ja, und die meisten haben wahrscheinlich Passwörter 123456.
Ich ja auch.
Ja.
Wer hier im Stream öfters dabei war,
wo ich irgendwelche Accounts, irgendwelche Fake-Accounts angelegt hab.
Bestes Passwort 123456.
Moment, ist das überhaupt das Richtige, was ich hier...
Moment, ist das das Falsche, was ich gestartet hab?
Ich kack nur.
Ja, zumindest...
Ich weiß nicht genau, welche Kabelfritzbox ich mir holen soll.
Ich brauche nämlich...
Ich starte das mal nebenbei.
Übrigens will ich es auf Deutsch haben, nicht auf Englisch.
Ich kenne mein Passwort.
Ja, 123456.
Du bist aber in guter...
Du bist aber in guter Gesellschaft.
Hä?
Moment.
Habe ich wieder das Falsche geöffnet?
Alter, ich bin so dämlich...
Open...
Kann man nicht... Konnte man nicht Last Projects öffnen?
Oder sowas?
Oh.
Was machst du denn?
Ich mache meinen Chatlogger an.
Wo habe ich den denn?
Sag mal.
Wo habe ich meinen Chatlogger?
Wo ist mein Chatlogger hin?
Bin ich jetzt total beknackt?
Wo ist mein Chatlogger?
Wo habe ich meinen Chatlogger hin?
Das ist er nicht.
MonkaSmoke, ja?
Das ist nicht mein Chatlogger.
Wo habe ich meinen Chatlogger?
The fuck?
Das Ding.
Wie hieß das nochmal?
Wie habe ich den nochmal genannt?
PepegaBoard.
Ja?
Wo habe ich den denn hin?
Ist doch das hier?
Ja, klar. Ist doch das hier.
Manchmal bin ich echt schwer vorm Begriff.
Doch, das Richtige gewesen, was ich hier gestartet habe.
Ja.
Ganz wieder.
Ja, weil ich habe einen Chatlogger gebastelt.
Oder wir haben besser gesagt im Stream einen Chatlogger gebastelt für Twitch.
Dass ich die Fragen und Zeug nicht übersehe.
Was macht die Paketlieferer-App?
Kommt dazu noch am Stream?
Ja, die machen wir.
Ich hoffe, dass ich die Fragen und Zeug nicht übersehe.
Was macht die Paketlieferer-App?
Kommt dazu noch am Stream?
Ja, die machen wir.
Ich hoffe, dass ich die Fragen und Zeug nicht übersehe.
Was macht die Paketlieferer-App?
Ich hoffe, dass wir nächstes Wochenende das Ding auf GitHub hochladen können als Beta-Version.
Die Pakettracker-App.
Die hat mittlerweile alle Tracking- Sachen bis auf Amazon drinnen.
Die Pakettracking-App.
Und sie kann E-Mails scannen nach Paket-Nummern.
Werderboy96. Nice.
Subscriber.
So. Okay, jetzt mache ich aber das Richtige auf.
Noch mehr. Product GT. Twitch Prime.
Geht es aber ab hier.
Dankeschön.
Was macht dein Postkasten?
Du meinst den ESP32-Postkasten?
Der ist immer noch nicht
ver-IoT'd.
Sag mal,
das spackt mega rum.
Wo ist denn das Problem?
Läuft das jetzt?
Okay, Leute, ich habe keine Ahnung, was ich getrieben habe.
Ich habe es irgendwie
kaputt gemacht.
Okay, ich habe es irgendwie, ist auch egal.
Ich habe es irgendwie zerstört.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich gemacht habe.
F für das PPGA-Board.
Wie geht denn das? Wie kann ich das kaputt gemacht haben?
Was hat der hier für Schmerzen? Wo ist das Problem?
Läuft das jetzt nicht rum?
Crap, da.
F-Board.
Fuck.
Und warum runnt er das nicht? Was ist das denn?
Ja, das ist doch drin.
Port 5 da außen. Richtig.
Das ist genau das Richtige.
Warum runnt er das nicht?
Was ist das Problem?
Ähm, wie bilde das denn?
Okay.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich glaube, ich habe ein Paketupdate gemacht und jetzt spackt es.
Ist auch egal.
Zumindest frage ich mich gerade,
ähm,
ob sich das lohnt,
das Ding zu kaufen, weil das ist
übertrieben teuer
und kann ich viel mehr als die andere.
Überlegt euch das mal.
Die würde mir theoretisch
gar nicht ganz...
Moment, Moment, ich gucke das falsch.
Ich brauche die Kabelfritzbox.
Hier. Genau.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich mir das Ding holen soll,
ob sich der Aufpreis lohnt, weil guck mal.
Die kostet 269
und die kostet 194.
Was für ein Mucke ist das?
Das ist irgendein, irgendein, ähm,
Music No Vocals
Chillstep Mix 2016.
Study, Focus, Work.
Also, Leute,
für Big Brains.
Ähm,
ich weiß halt nicht, ob sich das lohnt, ehrlich gesagt,
weil ich, also,
also, prinzipiell würde ich sagen, ja,
wer weiß, vielleicht habe ich Gigabit,
irgendwann mal mit Unity Media.
Hast du das mit Mailscan im Stream gemacht?
Nee, habe ich nicht, habe ich nicht im Stream gemacht.
Aber ich kann's, ich kann's
nachher zeigen. Mich ärgert, dass das
mein Chatlogger kaputt ist, das geht mir voll auf den
Sack. Mein Chatlogger kaputt.
Ich mache jetzt mal, ich mache jetzt mal im Hintergrund ein Paketupdate.
So, und dann gucken wir uns ein bisschen YouTube-Comments an.
So. Ähm,
was ist DOCSIS und DOCSIS 3?
Das sind Kabelmodem-Standards.
Oder Kabel, Kabelstandards.
Ist im Prinzip
ein bisschen was,
wie diese Geschichte, die sie mit DSL hatten,
wo sie dann mit Vectoring angefangen haben
und dann mit Super Vectoring und so gedünst.
Also, ist ein bisschen in die Richtung.
Ja, nur dass es was, was Standardisiertes ist.
Äh, Frage,
wieso braucht man so viel Download-Upload?
Ja, zum
Downloaden und Uploaden?
Ah, wenn du was runterlädst,
mehrere Gigabyte, dann
fürs 400 MBit Upload, nice.
Und, ähm,
wenn du Videos hochlädst oder aber streamst,
ist natürlich 40 MBit Upload auch gut.
Zumal man sich ja überlegen muss,
in Kombination mit,
wenn man, wenn man spielt
und die Leitung quasi dicht macht mit irgendwas,
spielt es sich natürlich auch nicht sonderlich gut.
Deswegen ist es eigentlich, eigentlich ganz nice.
Ja, der Sibaro, das war klar,
dass der hier wieder,
ah,
der Sibaro klein wieder.
So, also fangen wir mal an.
Also, wie gesagt, mich würde es mal interessieren,
ich weiß nicht, ob jemand von euch schon die,
die sich die neue, ich bin ja eigentlich gar kein Fan
von, äh, von Fritzboxen an sich.
Wir haben früher immer gesagt,
das ist die rote Pest, AVM,
aber das ist vielleicht ein bisschen drastisch, das Ganze.
Ähm,
ich weiß ja nicht, ob sich das lohnt.
Wobei ich glaube, ich, ich, ich werde mir
doch wirklich die hier bestellen.
Und, gewöhnlich versandfertig
in 1 bis 2 Monaten?
Was ist denn mit denen los?
Ole3,
okay, dankeschön, Subscriber.
Was ist denn ihr Ernst?
Sind die Leute so geil auf der neuen Fritzbox?
Teurer ist nicht immer besser.
In der Regel bei Fritzboxen tatsächlich schon,
weil die neu-, weil die Teureren einfach
das alles können, was die Alten können,
bloß noch ein bisschen mehr.
Aber generell ist das Fritzbox-Zeug, ähm,
relativ teuer, aber ich finde es angemessen.
Muss ich jetzt auch mal sagen, ähm,
ich finde es, warum, warum, warum sind die Leute
so geil auf der Fritzbox?
Aber ich muss sagen, ich finde die ganze Fritzbox-Geschichte,
die Fritzbox-Geschichte angemessen, weil es gibt nichts Vergleichbares,
was so viele,
so viele Funktionen
in einem Gerät hat. Ich meine,
nix davon ist wirklich herausragend.
Die Firewall in Fritzboxen, die ist
nicht existent, die suckt. Ähm,
die Routing-Funktionen in der Fritzbox sind fast
nicht existent, die sucken.
Ähm, WLAN-Unterstützung
hat eine Fritzbox nicht.
Alles mögliche, also, eine Fritzbox ist kein,
kein Router, kein Modem,
kein Fax, kein Anrufbeantworter,
kein Deck-Ding, so, so richtig,
die Fritzbox ist nix richtig, aber
von allem ein bisschen was.
Seit wann streamst du? Seit zwei Jahren oder so?
Asus-Router, die mag ich nicht.
Asus-Router mag ich nicht,
weil, also, erstens sehen die aus
wie, ähm, wie Stelzbomber,
und zweitens haben die jedes Mal,
guck dir mal das Ding an,
das, das sieht eher aus wie so, wie so
eine, wie so eine Drohne. Wenn du die um, wenn du
die umdrehst, kannst du Leute, die Angst
vor Spinnen haben, übelst erschrecken.
Stellt euch mal vor, ihr habt Angst
vor Spinnen, ihr stellt das Ding,
andersrum hin, ja,
und dann macht ihr ne Lampe daneben, und ihr
wacht nachts auf, und guckt so
Richtung Tür, und das Ding wird von der Lampe
angeleuchtet.
Da kackt ihr euch ein bei.
Das sieht cool aus, findest du?
Das, das
sieht beknackt aus, aber,
muss sagen, ich bin vorbelastet, was Netzwerkgeräte
angeht. Für mich sehen
Netzwerkgeräte ungefähr so aus.
Für mich sehen Netzwerkgeräte
ungefähr so aus.
Die sehen halt so nach nichts aus, ne?
So sieht für mich ein Netzwerk, so sieht
für mich ein Switch aus. Einfach, einfach
nach, nach Switch.
Ohne irgendwas.
Moin, Jodi XD.
Hansen 00, Twitch Prime. Nice, dankeschön.
Monka Smoke, ich wusste,
dass euch Monka Smoke gefällt.
Wobei, mein persönlicher,
mein persönlicher Favorit ist immer noch Wubblul.
Wubblul ist das Beste.
No game, no life.
Kann ich das überhaupt lesen?
Twitch Prime. Nice, dankeschön.
Wisst ihr,
für jeden Sub, für jeden Sub,
ich hab's schon öfters gesagt, heute,
für jeden
Sub steigt der kollektive
Chat, Chat, Chat,
Chat, wir sind nicht in Afrika, zu lull.
Steigt der Chat-IQ
um ein Pixel.
Okay, also,
ähm, lange genug ausgelassen über irgendwelche
Fritzbox-Sachen.
Ja, jetzt muss ich mich, bevor, bevor wir uns die YouTube-Comments angucken, ne,
ähm,
eine Sache, was, was ich, was ich
ziemlich frustrierend finde,
wenn man wieder anfängt mit YouTube.
Das hab ich das letzte Mal schon gemerkt.
Die Sache ist die, ihr seht's ja hier,
ähm, ich hab gerade
277.483
Und, wenn man sich mal Social Blade anguckt,
ich zeig euch jetzt mal was,
Social Blade,
da wird man feststellen,
jedes Mal, wenn ich mit YouTube anfange,
passiert erst mal das hier.
Das ist der erste Tag, wo ich was Neues hochlade,
und dann, das ist irgendwie so ein
interner YouTube-Sortier-Algorithmus,
das, das hier, das ist der erste Tag, wo ich was
hochgeladen hab.
Ähm, YouTube hat irgendwie so einen
internen Sortier-Algorithmus.
Ich weiß, anders, anders, anders
check ich das nicht. Das hab ich nämlich die letzten
Male schon gemerkt, wenn ich, wenn ich Wochen,
oder Monate inaktiv war. Das erste,
was YouTube macht, ist,
die räumen irgendwie inaktive Subs
auf, wenn man Videos hochlädt.
Ganz merkwürdig. Ähm,
klar, es, es kommt natürlich
auch noch dazu,
ähm, dass vielleicht der ein
oder andere Leute das in ihrer Subbox
haben und sagen, oh, hier, der Depp,
das will ich mir nicht mehr angucken, oder so, das kann natürlich auch
sein, aber es ist auffällig, es ist
echt auffällig, dass es immer
nur, dass die Bursts quasi
immer nur den Tag
verteilt über den Tag nach dem
Upload kommen. Und das geht
ungefähr,
man sieht's ja hier immer. Es geht leider
nicht so ganz zurück, ja. Man sieht's ja hier immer.
Immer, wenn ich wieder aktiv geworden bin. Hier hab ich wieder
viel hochgeladen, hier hab ich wieder viel hochgeladen,
ähm, immer, immer an
der Stelle, wo ich viel hochgeladen hab, geht's, geht's
dann halt aufwärts, ne, sieht man ja.
Also immer, wenn ich lang viel hochgeladen hab, wohlgemerkt,
sieht man das immer gleich. Zack, das war
meine Aktivitätsphase vor einem Jahr zu
Weihnachten ungefähr. Und dann
wieder, und dann wieder hier davor. Also man sieht
das, ja. Das ist, das ist wirklich auffällig.
Und es ist jedes Mal so,
dass das, dass das übelst, übelst
runtergeht. Und es dauert so,
sag mal, 14 Tage.
14 Tage dauert's ungefähr,
bis, bis YouTube das
wieder gecheckt hat, dass man regelmäßig hochlädt
und alle Subs aufgeräumt hat.
Und das Problem dabei ist, dass
das vor allem am Anfang übertrieben
demotivierend ist.
Wenn du anfängst und machst, lädst
wieder Videos hoch, und das erste Mal
was du siehst, ist
Instant-D-Abos.
Oder hier, 55 D-Abos nach dem Video
gestern. Und das Video ist
ja nicht schlecht angekommen. Ich mein, das Video hat
so gute, so gute Like-Dislike-Verhältnisse
hat, behaupte ich jetzt mal,
wahrscheinlich kein Mensch, oder
kaum einer auf YouTube. Kennt ihr nen
anderen Channel, der 2,4k
Likes und 21 Dislikes hat?
Jetzt ernsthaft, das Verhältnis?
Kennt ihr noch irgendjemand, der sowas, der so viel
hat? Also,
so gute Like-Dislike-Verhältnisse gibt's eigentlich fast nie.
Also kann man nicht sagen, dass das Video
irgendwie schlecht angekommen ist, oder sowas.
Aber es ist halt YouTube-Sortierungsgeschichte.
Und das ist am Anfang wirklich extrem
demotivierend, kann ich euch sagen.
Deswegen mach ich das diesmal anders.
Ich hab so den Hang dazu, immer zu gucken,
wie das da mit Subs geht, nachdem ich wieder
was hochgeladen hab. Ich seh das ja auch bei mir
in den Statistiken. Ich hab,
sobald ich anfange hochzuladen, krieg ich
viel mehr neue Subs, oder generell viel mehr Subs
als vorher, aber hab
auch extrem viel
Disabos, genau.
Wir deabonnieren ja nicht mehr, wir disabonnieren
nur noch. Deswegen hab ich mir gedacht, diesmal
scheiß drauf, ist mir eigentlich vollkommen egal.
Ich werd einfach
nichts hochladen,
wo ich selbst
irgendwie kein
hundertprozentig gutes Gefühl hab, ne?
Also sprich,
weil ich hab mir so überlegt, wenn ich
ein hundertprozentig gutes Gefühl hab,
hinter dem Video, ja, wenn ich sag, ey,
du hättst an dem Video eigentlich jetzt
nix wirklich besser machen können, so direkt.
Natürlich, besser machen kann man immer was, aber
wisst ihr, wie ich mein?
Ich lad das hoch, schalt das frei,
und wenn ich freischalt, denk ich mir, Max, das ist ein richtig gutes Video,
das würdest du dir auch selbst angucken,
dann ist mir's egal. Weil sonst mach ich
da nicht weiter.
Das klappt sonst nicht.
Wenn ich mir das anguck, wenn ich mir jetzt erstmal
14 Tage Deabos angucken muss,
bis sich YouTube wieder erholt hat, dann hab ich mir wieder
keinen Bock mehr. Deswegen mach ich das jetzt so.
Ich mach einfach Videos,
und ich lad das hoch, wo ich 100%
davon überzeugt bin, und fertig.
So, so ist das, so ist das gedacht.
Mal gucken, mal gucken, wie gut das,
wie gut das Ganze funktioniert, ey.
Es wird zu wenig nice gesagt in meinen Videos.
Ich weiß, viel, sehr, sehr nice
sag ich öfters,
oder, oder, mega nice.
Hab ich übrigens den
armedxhunter
gesagt, hat subscribed, Tier 1.
Huge.
Bist du noch am Start? Glaub ich hab ich ganz vergessen, ne?
Also Chat, Chat-IQ
steigt, wie
ein Sub, hab ich ja gesagt.
Ein bisschen.
Wir haben schon, wir, also muss sagen,
Chat ist schon ganz schön, ganz schön intelligent heute.
Gestartet. Normalerweise
startet Chat-Intelligenz
ungefähr so, aber
ich hab gedacht, heute sind wir mal großzügig und
Chat-Intelligenz startet hier irgendwo so.
Ja. Und falls ich irgendwas
übersehe, Leute, müsst ihr Edwublos vorbeischreiben.
Ähm, weil leider
ist mein, mein Chat, mein Chatlogging
ist kaputt. Hier, da.
Ich weiß nicht, warum es nicht startet.
Keine Ahnung. Ähm.
Deswegen seh ich das nicht.
Ich seh's zwar auf meinem Vorschau-Bildschirm links,
aber ich, ich hab keine History.
Das heißt, so viel Chat, wie hier gerade
gechattet wird, seh ich das nicht.
Deswegen, falls ich irgendwas übersetzt, übersehe,
komplett, müsst ihr mich noch mal
anschreiben.
Ähm, für den normalen, der Hexor sagt,
für den normalen Haushalt
sind die Kisten von AVM
absolut top und laufen in der Regel ohne große
Zigarren. Ja, ich weiß, ich find, ganz ehrlich,
ich fand früher AVM, hab ich AVM
immer geflamed. Ich sag ja, wir haben damals so,
so Zeiten, wo ich noch ein bisschen Netzwerkzeug gemacht hab
oder mehr Netzwerkzeug, haben wir immer aus Spaß gesagt.
Die Rote Pest aus Berlin.
Ich glaub, AVM kommt aus Berlin. Ähm.
Aber
mittlerweile muss ich sagen, das ist,
das sind richtig gute Kombi-Geräte.
Die sind in nichts gut, ja.
Wie gesagt, die Routine-Funktionen sind, sind räudig.
Ja.
GetSwifty1997, hab ich dich schon erwähnt, auf jeden Fall.
Ole3, auch nice. Ich bin mir gar nicht
sicher, ob ich euch alle vorgelesen hab, aber
danke für die ganzen Subs.
Warum eigentlich Fritzbox? Die Dinger sind
zu teuer für das, was sie bieten.
Die find ich gar nicht.
Ich find, dass das eigentlich recht angemessen ist
für das, was man kriegt.
Ich mein, du kriegst von allem etwas.
Versuch mal, gute, einzelne Geräte
zu finden. Versuch mal, nen guten, nen guten
Deck-to-Vibe-Geschichte zu finden,
der sich so easy konfigurieren lässt.
Und jetzt kein, jetzt nicht sagen, irgendwie
einen Asterix aufsetzen oder sowas.
Das ist ja auch keine, keine
Alternative. Oder,
wenn ein BilligNAS braucht, ist mit
der Fritzbox auch gut dabei. Wenn ein
Gäste-WLAN, für Easy-Mode-Gäste-WLAN
braucht, ist auch gut dabei.
Für mich, für mich ist die
Deck-Funktion wichtig. Für mich ist
die, ähm, Kabel,
Kabel-Streaming-Funktion wichtig.
Kabel-TV-Streaming-Funktion wichtig.
Ähm,
dass, dass das gut mit den Fritzfonds
zusammen kann, dass man schön, schön, ähm,
seine, seine, ähm,
Nextcloud-Kontakte synken kann
und sowas in der Richtung. Also ich find,
für das, was die Fritzbox bietet, ist die gar nicht so übel.
Du sagst, dass du eventuell mehr
Technik-Videos und Mythen machen
willst.
Äh, warte mal,
ähm, was, äh,
denn so im Stil von TheTurtleTubes,
die leider nichts mehr machen,
ich kann mich da gar nicht mehr richtig dran erinnern.
Weiß ich nicht, muss ich mal gucken.
Max, du hattest vor ein paar Jahren mal so eine
Serie gestartet, wo du am Ende eines Jahres
gute PC-Bilds vorstellst. Hättest du sowas Interesse,
wenn du Technik-Krams machen willst?
Ja, ich würde ganz gerne was,
also ansonsten kann ich immer ihn hier
empfehlen.
Also fähige Leute,
zumal man es auch bei ihm direkt bestellen kann.
Und da weiß ich, dass die sich tatsächlich, äh,
wirklich große Mühe
geben, ja.
Ähm,
den kann ich immer empfehlen. Und ich hab mir überlegt,
ob wir nicht zu Weihnachten zusammen wieder
ein Video, Technik-Video-Krams
machen können, wie letztes,
vorletztes Jahr?
Wann haben wir ein Video zusammen gemacht? Ich glaub, letztes Jahr haben wir ein Video
zusammen gemacht. Das wär nice.
Hehehe, Evoli, genau.
So, also fangen wir mal die YouTube-
Comments an, sonst schwärzen wir wieder so lang.
Also, es gab wirklich
richtig nice Comments diesmal.
Muss man sagen.
Ähm, die Call of Duty
Fanboys waren wieder am Start. Ich wollte
schon ein Video machen, so nach dem Motto
Max Flame Zuschauer oder sowas in der Richtung.
Aber ich hab mir gedacht,
wir müssen es ja nicht übertreiben, wir machen einfach einen Stream, wo ich euch
flamen kann.
Weiß, next level.
Ähm, was hältst du von Ubiquiti?
Äh, gut, die,
ich hab zwei, ich hab zwei Sachen von denen.
Stimmt nicht. Drei.
Drei Sachen. Ich hab zwei Access Points.
Zwei, äh,
mittlerweile hab ich zwei
Access Points von denen. Und
nen 10-Gigabit-Switch.
Und den da.
Zwölfmal SFP Plus
10G und
viermal Kupfer 10G.
Wo ist denn der Dark Mode, den?
Das ist ne gute Frage, hab ich nicht an.
Den könnte ich aber mal anmachen.
Bam.
Dark Mode active, der sieht aber kacke aus, der Dark Mode.
Hatte YouTube nicht selbst
mittlerweile nen Dark Mode?
Sag mal, hatte YouTube nicht selbst nen Dark Mode
mittlerweile?
Die hatten doch selbst nen Dark Mode, glaub ich.
Oh, wo kann man den einschalten? Hier?
Ah, Dark Theme.
Da, wunderbar.
Huge. Huge Dark Theme.
Ja, das ist doch schon viel angenehmer.
Viel angenehmer.
Moin
aus Trier.
Moin zurück.
Ich hab leider kein Winky
Emote.
Es gab hier wirklich viele, viele nice Comments.
Ich geh das jetzt mal schnell durch.
Also wir gucken uns nicht jedes einzelne
Comment an. Ich hab so ungefähr im Kopf
was
für gute Comments gegeben hat.
Also was ich sehr nice fand, vor allem im ersten
Video, das ist ja das erste, was ich wieder hochgeladen hab.
Das so viele Leute
noch am Start waren, vor allem so viele Leute,
die 2010 auch schon
dabei waren, wenn du das hier liest.
Ich mein, im ersten Video ist...
Was ist das eigentlich für ne Thumbnail hier bei der
Gamestar wieder?
Wahrscheinlich
ist diese Szene
in dem Video 3 Sekunden
lang und
voller Debate
um das Video anzuklicken.
You've got
debated.
Hehehe.
Ähm,
ja, also das fand ich sehr nice, dass so viele Leute
noch von 2010 dabei sind.
Ähm, dual mit dem Friseur,
das wird wahrscheinlich nix.
Das, äh, ich hab immer noch Kontakt
mit dem Fabian, ja. Also ich mein, ich kannte den Fabian
vor YouTube schon.
Ich kenn ihn natürlich immer noch.
Aber der Fabian hat keinen Bock mehr auf YouTube.
Ich geh dem ab und zu schon mal auf den
Keks, dass wir
was machen, aber der will
nicht. Hallo Donk,
aber der will nicht. Ich glaube,
das wird nix. Also, ein Video
zusammen mit dem Fabian wird wahrscheinlich kompliziert.
Moin,
Knalli, Bär?
Auf den Keks, versteht ihr.
Woblul, äh,
Woblul. Moin,
wie geht's deinen Hoden?
Was interessiert dich das?
Was geht das, geht das in Richtung
Tof, wa?
Es ist keine Schande mehr
heutzutage, ja?
Kannst ruhig fragen, musst dich nicht schämen für...
Aber ich kann dich beruhigen,
es ist alles in bester Verfassung, alles.
Wunderbar. Also du halt
mit dem Friseur willst wahrscheinlich nicht gehen, weil der Friseur keinen Bock hat.
Um's mal kurz zu
sagen.
Warum hat der Evoli keinen Keks vorm Namen? Stimmt,
warum hat der Evoli keinen Keks vorm Namen?
Ich glaub, da muss ich dem Evoli mal einen Sub
spendieren.
Ach, ich kann ja wieder nicht.
Boah, das funktioniert ja auf meiner Vorschauf...
Boah, alter, Sibaro ist ja gut!
Jetzt übertreibt
man nicht!
Da brauch ich ein extra, brauch ich ein extra Emote für.
Der Sibaro wieder hier mit
wie viel Subs haben wir hier? 1, 2,
3, 4, 5, 6, 7,
8, 9, 10 Subs!
Und insgesamt hat der Sibaro schon
28 Abos
gesponsert.
Sibaro, hast du nicht erst
deine Ausbildung fertig gemacht?
Gib mal dein Geld sinnvoll aus,
gib das nicht mir.
Ich hab schon genug.
Komm mal mit über die Runden, du musst ja nicht...
verausgaben.
Aber Dankeschön für die ganzen
Abos!
Den haben wir jetzt am Start, alle gesponsert vom Sibaro.
Den Flamehaze haben wir.
Der ist auch öfters am Start.
Baden, der Boss FTV, der kommt mir auch
bekannt vor.
Snowgde.
Dann haben wir den Morpheus420.
Presk.
Onehandproject.
L33333333333
On!
GermanTay und
ChooseMyName, der ist auch öfters am Start.
Helldog, Österreich,
auch am Start. Pock, Dankeschön.
Und dann Noah0302,
Twitch Prime. Leute, jetzt ist es ja mal gut hier.
Jetzt übertreibt es mal nicht.
Komm ich halt zu nichts.
Toss? Ja.
Wobei, was heißt
Toss? Eigentlich müsste ich jetzt
gerade, jetzt gerade, müsste ich einen riesen Sellout starten.
So nach dem Motto, hab ich schon erwähnt,
dass wenn ihr euer Amazon Prime
Account mit Twitch verbindet,
das Ganze dann zu Twitch Prime kombiniert,
dass ihr einmal im Monat kostenlos
einen Streamer eurer Wahl unterstützen könnt
mit einem Tier-1-Sub.
Euch kostet das Ganze nix und dem Streamer bringt das
alle Vorteile, die ein normaler
Sub auch bringt. Plus ihr kriegt
natürlich nice Emotes.
Sowas wie WubLul, WubS,
WubOld und WubCup.
Was ihr sicherlich immer schon haben wolltet.
StarMack ist auch am Start.
Twitch Prime, dankeschön, nice.
Kannst du mal ein Dual mit dem
Dr. Kaboom machen, Max?
Ich hab in letzter Zeit wenig mit dem Kaboom zu tun gehabt.
Allerdings ist ein Dual mit dem Kaboom
wahrscheinlicher als mit dem Friseur,
weil der Friseur hat absolut keinen Bock mehr auf Youtube.
Ich geh das auf nen Keks.
Warum hab ich eigentlich
mein Keks-Avatar nicht drinnen?
Wie steht's mit einem Staubsäure? Läuft da schon Doom drauf?
Garantiert. Also Doom dürfte
das kleinste Problem sein.
Baba-Saft.
439, Twitch Prime.
Dankeschön, jetzt geht's aber ab.
Ich komm ja gar nicht zu nix.
Ich mein, ich will mich mal nicht beschweren als irgendwer.
Ups.
Das war das falsche.
Der Thomas.
M07.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Normalerweise zelebrier ich ja einen Sub
etwas mehr, aber grade geht's echt
Schlag auf Schlag. Danke für die ganzen Subs.
Ähm.
Öffne FIFA-Packs.
Mit Commander Krieger.
Also ich würd mit Commander Krieger was aufnehmen, aber
FIFA-Packs...
Vor allem allgemein
mal ne Frage in die Runde, Leute.
Ähm.
Warum gibt es so viele Leute,
die FIFA-Packs
kaufen? Außer,
wenn es irgendwelche
krassen
Influencer-Dudes auf Youtube sind,
die dann bei eskalieren.
Ihr kennt ja die FIFA-Pack-Openings.
Ey, Leute, was geht?
Dr. Swag ist wieder am Start und heute mach ich 50
FIFA-Packs auf. Alter, ich freu mich so.
Ich bin so gehypt, diese FIFA-Dinger jetzt endlich aufzumachen.
Und endlich gibt's wieder was Neues.
Und dann gibt's die anderen,
dann gibt's die anderen,
die das nicht hypen,
die immer so ganz cool sind.
So was in Richtung ApoRed.
Digga, ey.
Digga, hab ich schon... Mein neuer Song kommt.
Digga, kritischer Hase.
Die gibt's auch noch.
Aber die Dr. Swag eskaliert
Typen... Gibt's eigentlich eine,
die Dr. Swag heißt? Das wär irgendwie ein guter
FIFA-Pack-Opening-Name.
Nervenkitzel,
die Sucht, okay.
Kritischer Hase, ja. Das ist das einzige,
was ich mir da gemerkt hab.
Weiß gar nicht, ob der das überhaupt noch sagt.
Krasius, zwei Monate aktuell.
Nice, dankeschön.
Ich mein, das kann jeder machen,
was er will. Nur weil ich
keine FIFA-Packs kaufe, weiß ich nicht.
Dass ich Leute irgendwie verurteilen würde,
die sich FIFA-Packs kaufen,
ich kann's bloß nicht ganz nachvollziehen.
ApoRed ist noch ein Ding, ich weiß es nicht.
Ich hab mir das bloß gemerkt, dass der manchmal gesagt hat,
kritischer Hase. Und ganz, ganz wichtig,
heutzutage als
als, ähm,
Influencer, wie man das jetzt ja nennt,
das ist ja erst seit so
zwei, drei Jahren,
dass es da so ein richtiges,
drei Jahre, dass es da so ein richtiges
nices Wort für gibt, ja.
Du musst auf jeden Fall
irgendeinen schlechten
Rap-Song aufnehmen.
Zum Beispiel,
zum Beispiel kannst du dann, es ist im Prinzip
egal, was du sagst, du kannst das eh autotunen
oder sowas, aber so ein paar schlechte,
so ein paar schlechte, so ein paar schlechte
Reime und so ein paar
schlechte Sachen müssen da rein.
So nach dem Motto, was hab ich heute
auf Twitter gelesen?
Dein Vater ist blau wie das Discord-Logo.
Könnte man so Informatiker-Rap machen.
Hören wir jetzt den Song
von Bibi an. Hat die schon wieder was
Neues gesungen? Hat die schon
wieder was Neues gesungen? Ich hoffe nicht.
Ich glaub Dings hier,
ich glaub sogar Katja Graverwitzel
hat jetzt nen, hat jetzt auch irgendwas
gesungen. Nee, Alter, da muss
echt jeder singen.
Muss wirklich, muss
wirklich echt jeder singen mittlerweile.
Vor allem, da versteh
ich auch nicht, was die an der,
also ich kann mir ja verstehen,
ich kann ja verstehen, dass es Leute
gibt,
die Streamer oder YouTuber gucken
einfach nur, weil sie die geil finden.
Also mit geil finden meine ich jetzt nicht,
weil sie den Content geil finden und sowas,
also weil sie die Person geil finden, ja?
Weil denen da voll einer drauf abgeht. Kann ich verstehen.
Was ich nicht
verstehen kann ist,
warum man Katja Graverwitzel geil findet.
Der Lost hat es letztens
treffend gesagt, die sieht aus
wie ein, nee, wie hat er gesagt?
Fuck, ich krieg's nicht dazu an.
Das war die beste Beschreibung,
die ich da je gehört hab.
Die sieht aus wie ein invertiertes Bild oder irgendwie
sowas.
Die Beschreibung trifft's genau.
Das ist wie, wenn du einfach einen
Photoshop-Filter nimmst und dann machst du
Farbinvertieren und so ungefähr kommt mir das
teilweise vor, wie sie in den Videos rumspringt.
Ja, aber ey, selbst
wenn man notgeile Kiddies ist,
es gibt so viel
bessere auf YouTube oder auf Twitch,
die man sich angucken kann.
Es gibt sogar welche, die Kombination
ist selten, ja, geb ich zu, aber
es gibt ja sogar welche, die spielen
ganz gut und die
sehen auch gut aus.
Alternativ sucht man sich halt einfach jemand,
der nur gut aussieht.
Aber ich kann
das nicht verstehen.
Man hat doch mittlerweile eine Auswahl.
Guck, geht auf Twitch.
Geht auf Twitch in Just Chatting.
Geht da hin.
Du wirst so viele Mädels
finden hier und wenn wirklich irgendjemand
das nötig hat,
sich das anzugucken
wegen irgendwelchen Mädels, dann soll er sich doch
hier lieber irgendjemand raussuchen, der ihm
gefällt und da ein bisschen fanboyen,
anstatt sich Katja krasser Witze anzugucken.
Wozu?
Ich melde dich für eure Mission an, ja.
Was ist denn nun mit Kommentaren?
Ja stimmt, da hast du recht.
Why kein War Classic?
Weil wenn ich jetzt anfange mit War Classic,
mache ich keine YouTube-Videos mehr und keine Streams.
Chris Stonehenge abonniert auf
Stufe 1. Stonehenge?
Auf Stonehenge habe ich mal in Dark gespielt.
Der Server hieß damals so.
Da hat kein Mensch eine Ahnung, von was ich rede.
Übrigens, ich habe ja gesagt, mit jedem Sub
steigt der Chat-IQ.
IQ sagt man ja heute nicht mehr.
Heute ist ja alles stylisch.
Man ist noch nicht agil, man ist agile.
Mittlerweile sind wir eigentlich schon
durch die ganzen Subs, sind wir eigentlich schon
maximierter IQ für heute.
Ich würde sagen, wir müssen erstmal
ein IQ-Reset durchführen,
dass es überhaupt noch drauf passt.
Ah, dankeschön für den Sub, Chris Stonehenge.
Nice.
Heute dominiert
Real-Life-Footage.
Ja.
Das ist ja okay.
Habe ich ja nichts dagegen.
Bloß die Frage, wem man da beim Real-Life zuguckt.
Wie gesagt, Leute, ich habe es ja gesagt.
Eine Million Abos, Face-Reveal.
Ich mache das.
Problem ist nur,
ich werde nie im Leben eine Million Abos kriegen.
Aber ich habe mir was überlegt.
Ich habe mir was überlegt.
Das kann ich jetzt noch kurz loswerden.
Und zwar, man könnte, man könnte,
weil wir uns da im Chat immer so lustig drüber machen.
Ich habe gedacht,
ich muss mir was Realistisches,
ein realistisches Ziel setzen.
Habe ich gesagt, okay, 300.000 Subs.
Ich meine, da fehlen noch 23.000.
23.000. 300.000 Subs.
Also das heißt, dass ich das packe,
muss ich erstmal stabil uploaden.
Content, den die Leute sehen wollen.
Plus vielleicht auch noch ein bisschen
mit anderen was machen.
Dann ist das, denke ich,
ein realistisches Ziel.
Und dann mache ich hier, mache ich ein,
ASMR-Video,
wo ich geflüstert werde.
So was mache ich dann.
Das ist mir übelst peinlich,
das kann ich euch jetzt schon sagen.
Aber das ist wenigstens was,
das ist mir übelst peinlich,
aber bei 300.000 ist das so was,
wo ich mich dazu durchringen könnte,
sowas zu machen, ey.
Pain-Champ.
Das ist, das ist massiver Pain-Champ.
Das ist Cringe hoch 10, ja.
Please, no.
Schaut euch mal nicht so an,
sonst mache ich euch gleich 30 Minuten
ASMR
feuchte Mund-Geräusche an,
oder sowas hier auf YouTube.
Wollt ihr das wirklich haben, ja?
Nein, vergesst noch,
das mache ich nicht an.
Fuck.
Schon gleich die ersten,
oh ja, Craig, ja so, wuh, toll.
Dachte, ich kann euch damit jetzt
abschrecken, aber nee,
klappt mal wieder nicht.
Twitch-Chat, also Cute-Chat ist
abgehärtet gegen alles Mögliche.
Oh, YouTube-Comments,
wir wollten YouTube-Comments gucken.
Also, Dual-Kommentare mit dem Friseur
habe ich schon erwähnt.
Bleibt doch bitte dran,
das haben auch saumäßig viele Leute geschrieben.
Ich werde es versuchen,
wie gesagt, ihr habt es die letzten Jahre
gesehen, ich meine,
das Hauptproblem ist, kann ich jetzt mal sagen,
ich bin von YouTube da.
Übrigens, Leute, die von YouTube angerückt sind,
wollt ihr mal meinen Staubsauger sehen?
Ich kann euch nachher mal meinen Staubsauger
Web-Oberfläche von meinem Staubsauger zeigen.
Staubsauger Web-Oberfläche.
Ich habe ein Web-Interface auf meinem Staubsauger.
Sehr nice.
Ähm, was wollte ich denn jetzt sagen?
Fuck.
Genau, das Hauptproblem, was ich habe,
mit aktiv bleiben auf YouTube,
das ist das, was mir die ersten paar Jahre über geholfen hat,
ist, ich brauche ein Spiel, was ich
criten kann. Ich brauche ein Spiel,
was ich durchgängig
spielen kann.
Ich hatte zuerst massig Call of Duty,
danach hatte ich massig Battlefield,
von Bad Company 2
bis, ähm,
bis Battlefield 4
mit ein Ticken Hardline noch
und das fehlt
mir aktuell. Ich habe kein Criting-Game.
Overwatch
fanden die Leute auf YouTube nicht so geil,
allerdings spiele ich auch gerade kein Overwatch
mehr. Ich habe mir überlegt, ich könnte mal wieder,
weil immer noch, weil
immer noch Leute nach Overwatch fangen,
ich könnte mal meine Placement-Matches aufnehmen
und da so ein Best-of zusammenschnippeln.
So nach dem Motto
Ex-Pro-Lucio
suckt auf Lucio oder irgendwie sowas.
Apex, Apex
ist für mich das beste Battle-Royale-Game.
Von
Fortnite, PUBG und Apex.
Apex. Ähm,
altes Battlefield, ich habe eine Bad Company 2
Gameplay aufgenommen, das wollte ich demnächst hochladen.
Hast du deinen High-End-Klon noch?
Klar. Ist das so voller Cheater?
Apex, wirklich?
Ich hoffe, ich habe jetzt keine Subs übersehen,
so viele, die gerade gekommen sind.
Nein, wir haben alle.
Also ich versuch's, wie gesagt, ich kann
nichts versprechen, was Videos angeht. Ihr habt das
die letzten Jahre mitgekriegt, aber
ich probier's. Es hängt auch
ein bisschen daran,
ähm, also
Themen habe ich genug. Ich habe mir mittlerweile, ich habe mir
die ersten paar Tage so viel
aufgeschrieben und
richtig gute Ideen, zum Beispiel
heute im Discord eine richtig gute
Idee gehabt, ähm, so nach
dem Motto, halt Idee, indirekt
eigentlich nur Idee, wir könnten unser eigenes
Google Stadia bauen. Jetzt nicht,
wir mieten uns kein Rechenzentrum und bauen
Google Stadia servermäßig nach,
aber es gibt mittlerweile
richtig gute Software, die nix
kostet, wo man Low Latency
ähm, Spiele streamen
kann, von einem PC an ein
Endgerät. Und
das ist mit Sicherheit ähnlich gut, wenn man in der Nähe
wohnt, wie Google Stadia.
Wenn man, wenn man einen ordentlichen Gaming
PC hat, natürlich, ne.
Ich bin persönlich ja immer noch der Ansicht, dass
Google Stadia übelst floppen wird.
Und die letzten Jahre, muss man
zugeben, habe ich meistens ganz gut gelegen
mit Sachen, die floppen. Und
auch mit Sachen, die sich, das heißt, du magst
das Orakel, ich weiß, aber, und auch
Sachen, die sich durchsetzen. Ich habe euch von Anfang an
gesagt, als Pupke der Hype
schlechthin war und Fortnite
rausgekommen ist und alle gesagt haben, ah lull,
Fortnite beste, Pupke, Pupke viel besser
und so, Fortnite, habe ich damals
schon gesagt, vor einer, vor zwei Jahren oder so,
Leute, Pupke wird abscheißen,
höchstens in Asien, sogar
das habe ich damals gesagt, höchstens in Asien,
das ist, das ist hier, big brain
next level, aber
Fortnite wird sich durchsetzen. Und was ist?
In Asien ist Pupke noch beliebt
und, ähm,
Fortnite ist kacke.
In Asien. Und hier ist
Fortnite extrem huge und, äh,
Pupke interessiert sich nicht mehr so richtig
einer für.
Warum denkst du, das mit
Stadia?
Ähm, ich seh, ich seh nicht
so richtig, warum man sich das kaufen sollte.
Die größ, die größten, okay,
das ist ja, zählt ja quasi als, als Comment
beantworten. Die größten Teile
der Gamer, wenn man
sie mal so nennen darf, sind
mobile spielende Casuals.
Die spielen, äh,
was gibt's denn da so hier, Clash, Clash of Clans
und, und, äh,
Fappy Bird und
Geschiss, ja. Die Leute,
kaufen sich kein Stadia.
Allein schon, wenn die einen Controller in der Hand
haben, da denkst du, das ist für
die, das ist, das ist, das ist,
die checken nicht, die wissen noch gar nicht, worum man das halten soll.
Der Piep.
Ähm,
ich eigentlich dachte ich, der Witz ist so schlecht,
da steigt keiner drauf ein, ja.
Aber
anscheinend doch. Lol.
Ähm,
das wollte ich jetzt sagen.
Die werden sich wahrscheinlich auch kein Stadia
holen.
Was bleibt denn übrig?
Die Leute, die Hardcore Playstation
Fans sind,
warum sollten die sich Stadia holen?
Die wollen, die wollen Playstation Exclusives
spielen. Höchstens
die Xbox-Leute.
Davon gibt's zumindest in Deutschland nicht so viele.
Allerdings, die, die
wirklich auch große Xbox-Fans
sind und auf die Exklusivtitel wie Halo stehen,
die spielen die mittlerweile entweder auf der
Windows oder auf der Xbox. Und die wollen
wahrscheinlich auch kein Stadia. Also das einzige,
was übrig bleibt für Stadia sind,
sind eigentlich Leute,
die gerne PC
oder sagen wir mal, die gerne Spiele
spielen wollen.
Hauptsächlich im Singleplayer, weil über
Multiplayer vergiss es.
Ähm,
und
dafür sich
ein Abo holen wollen. Also ich sehe es jetzt
ehrlich gesagt nicht so richtig.
Ja, das weiß ich.
Stadia hat auch gesagt, sie sind
enttäuscht, wenn sie nur 2 Millionen User haben.
Das mag sein,
ich weiß nicht, aber Google,
sag mal, Google hat auch so ein bisschen
Geschichte in letzter Zeit, komische
Dinge rauszubringen. Ich mein, denk mal an Google Plus
und die Zwangsintegration mit YouTube und sowas.
Oder 200 Millionen?
Nicht 2 Millionen, 200 Millionen
waren's. Stimmt. 2 Millionen, 2 Millionen.
2 Millionen hat schon Mario Maker verkauft
wahrscheinlich.
Ja, deswegen glaube ich, dass Stadia floppen wird.
Die einzige Sache,
die Stadia glaube ich, ähm,
warum
sollten sich PC-Spieler Stadia holen?
Na zum Beispiel PC-Spieler,
die gerne PC spielen wollen, aber sich keinen PC holen
wollen. Oder halt generell Leute, die vielleicht
früher PC gespielt haben und sagen, hey,
ich würde auch aktuelle, ich würde gerne aktuelle
Singleplayer-Spiele auch spielen,
aber vielleicht halt unterwegs, vielleicht auch bei mir daheim,
aber ich hab keinen ordentlichen PC.
Ah, vielleicht. Multiplayer über Stadia.
Ähm,
kann funktionieren,
allerdings nur unter der Voraussetzung,
dass die restliche Welt auch Stadia verwendet.
Was die restliche Welt nicht tun wird.
Stadia Multiplayer
funktioniert nur, wenn du Lobbys
bilden kannst oder Server in
die Google Cloud stellen kannst, dass quasi
die Latency
zwischen dem Spieler und den Servern
wegfällt. Also die nochmal extra Latency.
Also du hast ja schon Latency durch Input und
Streaming an denjenigen,
der Stadia verwendet,
aber wenn wenigstens die Spieler untereinander
auf dem gleichen Server sind, so ein bisschen wie
bei einem MMO, dann könnte das funktionieren,
aber das klappt nur, wenn die ganze Welt
Stadia für Multiplayer verwendet.
Oder aber
Stadia spielt isoliert miteinander.
Ich versteh's auch nicht.
Wenn die mir nicht zeigen...
Ich sag euch mal, was das einzige ist,
was mich, ähm,
was mich überzeugen würde,
dass Stadia
spielen,
lokales spielen,
ähm,
übertrumpfen könnte. Das einzige.
Das einzige, wo die mir das
erzählen könnten ist,
wenn
CSGO
ein Team
ein Major gewinnt über Stadia.
Dann glaub ich denen,
dass das so
revolutionär ist, wie sie, wie sie,
wie sie tun.
Das wird aber nicht passieren.
Kein CS Pro spielt freiwillig
nen Major über Stadia.
Die lachen, die lachen nicht
aus, wenn du das denen vorschlägst.
Das ist das einzige, wo
sie mich überzeugen könnten.
Aber ansonsten, ne.
Hat Stadia schon jemand mal ausprobiert?
Wie ist das mit der Latenz?
Ich hab letztens nen Artikel
zu Stadia gelesen, wo sie
irgendwie mit 200 Millisekunden
rumgekrebst sind. Das halt ich persönlich
für ein bisschen hoch.
Ähm...
Es ist aber auch
nix Neues. Das muss man ja auch mal sehen.
Diese ganze Gaming on Demand
Streaming-Geschichte, die gibt es
seit 2012
oder so. OnLive
war eines der ersten Dinge. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob OnLive
überhaupt noch gibt.
Die haben wir im Betrieb 2011,
2015 eingestellt.
Dazu kommt ja noch, dass es
Playstation Now gibt oder wie das ganze heißt
oder sowas in der Richtung. Also Stadia
ist jetzt ja nix Neues. Das einzige,
das ist der einzige riesen Vorteil, den
Youtube hat, äh, nicht den Youtube hat,
den Google hat, ist
ihre Infrastruktur.
Vor allem die Länder,
wo es irgendwie Google Fiber und so Gedöns
gibt.
Ähm, das ist der einzige
Vorteil, den Google im Vergleich zu anderen
Anbietern hat, dass sie eben massig Infrastruktur
haben. Und das ist übrigens
auch das einzige, wie das funktionieren wird.
Wenn du Game Streams und sei es Singleplayer,
die Server müssen
irgendwo bei dir in der Nähe stehen.
Weil schneller als Lichtgeschwindigkeit geht
halt nichts. Wie soll das funktionieren?
Ich mein, Google hat zwar schlaue
Leute, aber wenn sie es schaffen würden,
die Daten schneller als Lichtgeschwindigkeit zu übertragen,
ich glaube, dann wären die Leute nicht mehr bei Google.
Da würden die, würden die
gesamte Menschheit revolutionieren.
Und nicht Stadia bauen.
Und ansonsten, wo die Zeit drauf
geht, ist ja nicht unbedingt bei der
reinen Übertragung, ja,
jedes Paket, was irgendwie geroutet werden
muss, bei jedem Hop, landet es mal
kurz in einem Buffer, muss Lookup
gemacht werden, Tabelle. Das sind immer,
immer Millisekunden, halbe Millisekunden,
je nachdem, was ist unterwegs. Und wenn
du da 80
Hops dazwischen hast oder so, dann wird
das nix. Das kann nicht ordentlich
funktionieren.
Das Komprimieren, das dauert.
Es ist, es ist nicht ohne.
Hehehe.
Max vor 3 Stunden erst mal Comments lesen. Max jetzt
Google Stadia. Ja, ist doch fast
ein Comment, ja. Stadia kam mir sogar in den Comments
manchmal, manchmal vor.
Muss, muss man, muss ich jetzt einfach mal loswerden.
Hab ich jetzt irgendwas überlesen?
Oh, der Presk hat gefragt,
ich mach zur Zeit eine Ausbildung als
Fachinformatiker und habe irgendwie keine Ahnung,
ob ich einen Praktikumsplatz für meinen
Abschluss... Wie kannst du eine Ausbildung
als Fachinformatiker machen und du brauchst
einen Praktikumsplatz? Wenn du eine Ausbildung
als Fachinformatiker hast, hast du doch einen
Arbeitsplatz.
Hä? Das check ich nicht.
Das ist zu next level für mich.
Ach, Umschulung.
Ah, du hast was anderes gelernt und machst jetzt quasi
zusätzlich nochmal was, dass du Fachinformatiker
kriegst. Äh,
gute Frage.
Keine Lust auf so einen Ausnutzerbetrieb.
Ganz ehrlich, wenn du da ein Praktikum
machen willst, das geht, wie lang
geht das? Acht Wochen?
Scheiß doch drauf, ob das ein
Ausnutzerbetrieb ist.
Du musst dich ja nicht ausnutzen lassen.
Die können dich eh nicht rausschmeißen.
Nach drei Monate.
Also wenn du natürlich die Möglichkeit hast,
was ordentliches zu finden, natürlich, dann würde
ich auf jeden Fall was interessantes nehmen, keine Frage.
Aber wenn es einfach nur darum ging, dass du
den Krams jetzt endlich hinter dir hast,
ähm,
musst du ja eh dein Projekt machen.
Also sprich,
drei Monate Lager aufräumen geht überhaupt nicht.
Drei Monate Lager aufräumen
ist nicht Bestandteil der Ausbildung.
Und außerdem bist du ja da, um dein Abschlussprojekt zu machen.
Also ich glaube,
au- außerdem, kommt noch dazu,
so viele, es ist jetzt ja auch nicht so, dass jeder,
dass jeder Betrieb irgendwie die übelsten
Ausnutzer wären, ja? Es gibt da schon
genug Leute, die sich Azubis
einstellen, um äh, quasi
billige Arbeitskräfte zu haben, aber die
meisten sind das bei weitem nicht.
Die meisten
sind vielleicht unfähig, aber die meisten
haben nicht gezielt vor, die Leute auszubeuten
in der Richtung.
Drei Monate im Bergwerk.
Was will- Fachinformatikerausbildung
im Bergwerk.
Was willst du denn
im Bergwerk Fachinformatikern?
Raspberry Pi für
Fahrstuhlsteuerung. Dann geht das Ding kaputt
und die Leute kommen nie wieder raus.
Also, aber ich muss dir sagen, Vorschläge habe ich nicht so wirklich.
Was ganz okay ist,
was du machen könntest, ist, ähm,
bei irgendeinem Shopportal,
heiße Jobs, äh,
oder irgendwas, irgendeinem
Shopportal, einfach mal zu gucken,
wer Fachinformatiker
oder wer generell, ähm, also einmal
wer Fachinformatikerausbildungsstellen anbietet,
die sind natürlich nicht verkehrt, mal zu fragen,
kannst du nicht da dein Praktikum machen? Es gibt auch welche,
die haben explizit, wenn du dann auf die
Homepage gehst dieser Leute, in Jobportals
haben sie keine Praktikumsstellen drinstehen,
meistens, aber du kannst auf das,
du siehst ja auf dem Jobportal meistens, wer es ist,
sei das so ein Anonymisierungsding,
und, ähm, dann kannst du bei denen mal
auf der Homepage gucken, ob die nämlich Leute
suchen für ein Praktikum, manche schreiben viele
mittlerweile auch auf die, auf die Webseite,
ähm,
und ansonsten, ganz ehrlich, such dir
irgendwas,
was bei dir in der Nähe ist,
dass du das, dass du die drei Monate
easy auf einer, auf der halben Arschbacke machst,
und, ähm,
du machst ja eh dein Projekt
da, die könnte ich ja gar nicht großartig ausbeuten.
Okay, weiter geht's.
Das haben auch sau viele Leute geschrieben,
die sagen, dass sie sich freuen, dass Videos wieder am Start sind,
sie haben das früher geguckt, wo sie zwölf waren, oder so,
okay, aber, und da hab ich mir gedacht,
Alter, jetzt übertreibt das, ne, einer hat geschrieben,
irgendwie, aber zwölf, wo er angefangen hat, meine Videos zu gucken,
das Problem ist,
das ist ohne Probleme möglich,
ich hab 2010
angefangen, wenn er 2000,
äh, wenn er 2010 zwölf war,
das sind neun Jahre, dann ist er jetzt 21,
quick maths,
überlegt euch das mal,
krass, oder?
Jemand, der mit zwölf
angefangen hat, meine Videos zu gucken, ist jetzt 21,
kann man sich das vorstellen?
Heftig, oder?
Ich mein, ich ja auch,
ich hab angefangen mit paar'n 20,
jetzt bin ich, ja,
whoop old bin ich jetzt,
bin ich 35,
eine Runde mal
whoop old für mich in Chat, wer, wer kann,
war richtig
whoop old,
feels old champ,
fühlt sich immer noch jung an,
ich weiß, ich hab mich schon immer angehört, wie
14, oder so,
neue Emotes, ja,
okay, ähm,
ich mach ja meine Thumbnails
immer noch mit Affinity Designer,
meine Thumbnails sind, äh,
jetzt nicht sonderlich gut,
aber es ist auf jeden Fall besser, als sich auf irgendwelche
Designsort zu verlassen,
die alle paar Monate nicht mehr wollen,
anders überlegt haben oder so oder jetzt minecraft reaction sonst was youtuber
sind oder ich weiß gar nicht was macht er denn jetzt eigentlich macht mir gibt
sie noch ja die gibt es noch immer noch ordentlich views
das zumal mittlerweile haben meine ehemaligen samtl designer zehn mal mehr
abos und views als ich 50 mal mehr 50 mal mehr abos und views als ich ist aber
nicht so dass ich keinen können wird letztendlich ich finde den kontakt immer
ein bisschen fragwürdig von manchen leuten aber wenn es wenn es wenn es einem
gefällt war das nicht auch der mit geld ist geld oder sowas astor zwei zwei
monate aktuell dankeschön ich sollte dann samtl designer werden
kannst du gerne machen
wenn du wenn du gut designen kannst ich kann es nicht guckt guckt ihr meine
thumbnails an also wann kommt die minecraft let's play reihe auf dem
staubsauger erstmal muss ich den kram irgendwie als erstes muss ich dem
staubsauger mal einen usb stick verpassen und hoffen dass er den erkennt
mach mal wieder ein laberstell mit plans vs zombies habe ich tatsächlich vor
es gab es letztens kostenlos bei origin ich habe erst letztens das flawless akimbo
gameplay von deon thunder angeschaut gute zeilen ja den gibt es auch noch
nicht niss letztens wieder was geguckt von dem aber da entkommt vier videos
mit frisier und diese dame geliebt keine ahnung wie sie heißt weil silvana
silvana die silvane gibt's auch noch diese pfanne ist ausgewandert so war
das letzte mal mitgekriegt haben silvane es ausgewandert hier kommen sie boner f below
أسي tony rafer das wird mir manchmal rauskommen oily komen
едиator
raus ja was meint ihr was überlegt euch mal leute der assi toni würde heutzutage dieses video
hochladen das ist ja mal so was von gar nicht 2019 feminismus tauglich der assi toni der wäre
ja der hätte ja die das war ja schon instant hate speech das wäre ja geteert gefedert gebannt
g4 teilt alles wäre heute worden da sie toni wissen noch alle dass du früher kurz auf der
xbox gespielt hast ja aber das ist fünf jahre oder so her das board kommt zur anwendung er
hat recht er hat nicht unrecht ja er hat nicht unrecht wenn ich aber sehr laut machen nichts
hochladen ist es natürlich ein bisschen blöd aber ich habe euch das gerade gezeigt mit den
statistiken erstens bringt abo sellout was die leute denken da einfach
nicht dran was motiviert tatsächlich wirklich ungemein weil man sieht dass es abos gibt aber
auch ein paar runden gespielt und mir gefällt es richtig dass die waffen sich wuchtig anfühlen und
nicht als hätte ich eine wasserpistole in der hand mit der diegel one shots verteilen ist verdammt
befrieden das stimmt das hat mir tatsächlich an der beta auch gefallen das fand ich das fand ich
angenehm der westersburg zum beispiel hat gesagt er mag das nicht er finde das fühlt sich ordentlich
und wie kot an wie geht es dem kaboom dem geht es gut das war schon ein bisschen komisch aber
eine weile nichts mehr gehört aber dem ging es zuletzt gut ich vermute jetzt immer noch gut
dem friseur jetzt auch gut von dem höre ich regelmäßig was der ist da ist alles aber der
friseur hat keinen bock auf youtube lieber kack thumbnails und cooler inhalt anstelle
cooles thumbnails und kack inhalte wie wäre es mit besonders kack inhalten clickbait titeln
und übertrieben aufgemotzten thumbnails weil das scheint am besten zu funktionieren
das ist next level richtig so muss man es an machen auf youtube aktuell wie kann man seinen
follow age einsehen keine ahnung was du meinst was familie ritter wird warum warum wird mir
familie ritter vorgeschlagen ich verstehe youtube nicht juckt familie ritter überhaupt nicht das
erste video hat als im größten teil daraus bestanden dass die leute sich freuen dass
wieder videos gibt das hat mich auch gefreut
huge gefreut ehre genau was mich sehr stark stört ist dieses platsch geräusch wo man einen
gegner trifft das macht das macht doch das gleiche hitmarker geräusch wie immer oder
dem kurs da ernsthaft wo ist er ich hab gar nicht gesehen da ist er max hast du das game
auf der konsole gezockt hab jetzt gar nicht aufgepasst dass du ein video hochgeladen hast
mich interessiert wie sich maus und tastatur auf der konsole anfühlt maus und tastatur auf der ps4
haben sich kacke angefühlt wie in dem video hat er gesagt ich bin ein kack und ich bin ein kack beim
Die PS4 hatte eine Maus-Abtastrate jenseits von gut und böse.
Das hat im Hauptmenü, hat sich die Maus ungefähr so bewegt.
Ingame hat sich besser angefühlt, aber nicht wirklich direkt und flüssig.
Ich meine, ich habe auf der einzigen Sense, die es ingame gab, gespielt und 800 DPI.
Und ich hatte es ungefähr so eingestellt, dass ich einmal über das Mauspad in 360 mache.
Und ich habe mich so übertrieben veraimt, dass es auf dem PC auf jeden Fall nicht vorkommt.
Und es funktioniert ganz gut.
Dazu kommt, dass ich mir noch so ein Cheat-Ding gekauft habe.
So ein, so ein, wie heißt das?
Diesen, diesen, ähm, ich habe schon wieder vergessen, wie dieses Teil heißt.
Steht auch kein Name drauf.
Diese XIM-Geschichte, weil ich mir gedacht habe, ey, ich komme überhaupt nicht mit Controller.
Klar, und mit Maus und Tastatur an diesem Controller-Adapter ist halt schon ganz schöner Beschiss.
Aber ich meine, warum nicht?
Nice.
PC Master Race, Konsolen-Plebs haben es nicht anders verdient.
Jetzt könnt ihr sagen, dis-Abo, Max, dis-Abo.
Max, nimm mal den Nazi-Frosch aus den Dumpnails.
Es ist mittlerweile ja, es ist mittlerweile fast alles Nazi.
Du kannst ja nichts mehr verwenden.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass Pepe Nazi ist mittlerweile.
Aber es ist fast alles Nazi.
Da gibt es ja nichts mehr.
Was ich schon alles, Alter, wenn ich mir das überlege auf YouTube, na, was mir schon alles vorgeworfen wurde.
Ich war schon alles.
Ich war von Jude bis Kanake bis scheiß Nazi.
Ich war alles auf YouTube schon.
Alles.
Je nachdem, was gerade einer haten wollte, war ich schon.
Max, würdest du empfehlen, Wirtschaftsinformatik zu studieren?
Kommt auf dich an.
Markierst du immer ein Wort oder ein Buchstabe?
Ja.
Das ist so eine Angewohnheit von mir.
Da haben wir auch ein Bot-Kommando.
Also, wenn du BWL-Zeug magst, plus ein bisschen Technik, dann warum nicht?
Ja.
Also, ich mache um alle BWL- und Wirtschaftssachen immer einen großen Bogen.
Aber das ist persönliche Geschichte.
Mit PS4-Remote-Play ging es einigermaßen.
Echt?
Man kann PS4-Remote-Play machen?
Mit Tastatur und Maus?
Ja?
Echt?
Pepe-Klaune.
Ja, Emco, du hast doch...
Du musstest...
Ich weiß, du musstest dir den gleichen Mist sicherlich auch schon anhören.
Alle, die auf die längere Zeit auf YouTube sind und, sag mal, eine gewisse Reichweite haben,
die waren schon alles mal.
Die wurden schon...
Du wurdest für alles schon geflamed, ja?
Du bist auch gleichermaßen Xbox-Fanboy, also, kack, Xbox-Fanboy, kack, Sony-Fanboy, kack, Microsoft-Fanboy,
kack, AMD-Fanboy, kack, Nvidia-Fanboy, du bist alles.
Immer.
Immer so, wie es passt gerade.
Ist halt einfach so.
Aber die meisten Leute, und ich denke mal, Emco, das ist bei dir auch so,
die meisten Leute bei uns sind vollkommen normal.
Sofern wir normal sind.
Sofern wir normal sein können, ja.
Ich meine, sie haben alle einen Dachschaden, ich ja auch, irgendwo.
Aber die meisten bei uns in den Comments sind wirklich sehr umgänglich und angenehm.
Und haben natürlich huge brain, klar.
Vor allem, wisst ihr, wer besonderes großes Gehirn hat?
Das sind alle Leute, die ihren Amazon Prime mit Twitch Prime verbunden haben.
Weil wenn du deinen Amazon Prime mit Twitch Prime verbunden hast, kannst du kostenlos einen Streamer unterstützen mit einem Prime-Abo.
Dafür kriegst du ein paar E-Mails.
Das sind E-Mails vom jeweiligen Streamer.
Kostet dich nichts und der Streamer hat alle Vorteile von.
Easy.
Schon getan.
Echt, Emco, wann hast du mich gestubbt?
Danke, nice.
Fragt mich nicht, warum ich jetzt das Java-E-Mode aufmache.
Einfach, weil es geht.
Weil Java, diese random E-Modes.
Naja, was heißt die E-Modes?
E-Modes sind nicht random.
Die sind calculated.
Die sind schon auf besonderem Level.
Level durchdacht, ja.
Trauma Michi, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön.
Wisst ihr, hat schon funktioniert.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Was ist dein All-Time-Favorite-Game?
Leute, ich mach euch einen Vorschlag.
Ich mach euch einen Vorschlag.
Wenn ihr so Fragen habt wie, was ist dein All-Time-Favorite-Game?
Oder wenn ihr dann am besten noch, ihr formuliert da irgendwie eine Video-Idee draus, die ihr gerne hören würdet.
Dann macht einfach...
Einfach mal Ausrufezeichen Discord.
Weil wir haben im Discord einen Channel für Themenvorschläge.
Ich kann mir das eh nicht alles merken jetzt.
Und haut's da rein.
Und wenn's ein guter Vorschlag ist, mach ich ein Video zu.
Und wenn's ein Video ist, was von einem Vorschlag kommt, werde ich auch noch reinpacen, von wem der Vorschlag ist.
Das ist doch was, oder?
Okay, was haben wir sonst noch für schöne Comments?
Battlefield Gameplay.
Leute, Battlefield Gameplay.
Bad Company 2 Gameplay ist schon aufgenommen.
Harvest Day.
Und Black Ops 1 Free For All ist aufgenommen.
Also von mir selbst jetzt nicht irgendwie.
Externe Gameplays wieder.
Solution hat nicht reagiert auf deinen Post.
Ich denke, der hat's einfach nicht gesehen.
Wir haben uns vor drei, vier Monaten schon mal überlegt, ob wir nicht was zusammen aufnehmen.
Also wir sind ganz unregelmäßig, haben wir uns die letzten Jahre mal wieder ab und zu was geschrieben.
Ich hab mir eh schon überlegt, ob ich nicht einfach mal, weil ich weiß, mir folgen ganz viele Oldschool-Leute und mir folgen viele Leute auf Twitter, die mal Oldschool waren und jetzt halt teilweise schon ziemlich groß sind,
ob ich nicht einfach mal auf Twitter posten sollte, wer hat Bock, was aufzunehmen mit mir.
Weil du musst heutzutage auf YouTube, guter Content allein ist so die halbe Miete, so ein bisschen Cross-Promotion muss sein.
Und wenn ich Apo Reds neuen Song remixen muss, ja, ne, man kann's auch übertreiben.
Ich mach einfach Back-Vocals.
Digga, kritischer Hase, digga, digga, yeah, come on, digga.
Äh, Flixcoder, Twitch Prime, dankeschön, pock.
Zwei Monate schon.
Oh, ich muss langsam mal einen Drei-Monats-Badge, einen Drei-Monats-Badge einführen.
Für meine...
Du find's super, äh, Gamestick sagt, hey, Max, find's super, dass du wieder Videos machst, bin definitiv gehypt auf mehr.
Ich auch, ich auch, ich hab übelst Bock.
Ich hatte heute die Auswahl, ich mach ein Video zum Thema, ähm, es hat einer ein richtig langes Comment geschrieben,
was für Bauchschmerzen er gerade mit, mit in der Schule hat und, und, und ausbildungsmäßig, mäßig,
und da hab ich mich wiedererkannt drin, da wollte ich eigentlich ausführlich was zu sagen,
aber ich hab gedacht, zwei Videos hintereinander ist ein bisschen, ein bisschen verschwendet,
auch wenn es ein wichtiges Thema ist, weil das Video, Sonntag hochgeladen, ist halt ein schlechter Tag, Sonntagabend,
ähm, hat, hat erst, glaub, 15.000 Aufrufe oder so, ich wollte schon warten, bis das bei ungefähr 20.000 ist,
bevor ich das nächste hochlade.
Kommt wieder mal BC2-Gameplay, ja, hab ich ja grad gesagt, ich hab schon was aufgenommen.
Optik Jellyfish, oh, echte, echter Optik-Player, echter Optik-Player?
Ja, dankeschön für den Prime-Zap.
Der M-Core sagt, jetzt muss ich nur noch hoffen,
dass Modern Warfare auch für den Mac rauskommt, jetzt, wo ich nur noch einen MacBook habe,
jetzt bereue ich's auf, Stadia, wo hatten wir's doch grade von?
Kauft ihr einfach, kauft ihr ein Spiel über Stadia, und, und regt nicht auf, dass das, ähm,
dass es laggt.
German Taters 2.0, nee, garantiert nicht, den Stress würd ich mir auch nicht geben,
zumal man da heute gar nicht die Leute für finden würde.
Du musst einfach nur Content für Kids machen an Selber-Durchstand, ja, aber,
das beißt sich mit dem, was ich am Anfang gesagt hab.
Ich hab am Anfang gesagt, ähm, ich werd, ich werd jetzt nen anderen Ansatz machen,
und zwar, wenn ich ein Video hochlade, ich lad nur noch Videos hoch,
wo ich hundertprozentig selbst davon überzeugt bin, dass es ein Video ist, was ich gucken würde.
Und da kann ich kein Kinder-Content machen.
Was mit Alt-F4, äh, mit, mit Tim hatte ich nie groß, äh, nix großartig zu tun.
Das Einzige, was ich mit Alt-, also mit, mit, ähm, mit, mit Alpha 4 Games je zu tun hatte,
war mal diese...
Also einmal wollten wir mal was zu Battlefield machen, aber das haben wir nie gemacht.
Und dieses, dieses, äh, Dead, Dead Space,
Drei-Zeilen-Programm, was ich da mal gebastelt hab.
Deadstampf 1 oder so.
Mach mal was mit M-Coin, äh, M-Coin, also Jan, wir müssen auf jeden Fall was zusammen aufnehmen jetzt.
Das bleibt, geht ja gar nicht anders.
Ich komm mit dem Chat heute überhaupt nicht nach.
Was ist denn hier los?
Mach irgendwas mit Monte, dann hast du deine Reichweite.
Ähm, wir kennen uns nicht sonderlich gut.
Ich weiß erstens nicht, ob er was mit mir machen will.
Und ich wüsste auch gar nicht genau, was, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das so gut zusammenpasst.
Ich war ja schon mal, vor Urzeilen hab ich so einen 20-Sekunden-Clip, war mal bei ihm auf dem Channel.
Ähm, in, in einem längeren Video, aber das war noch ganz am Anfang.
Und sogar das hat schon Abos gebracht damals.
Was?
Meine Katze an der Tür?
Kratzt die?
Wartet mal kurz.
Macht sie nicht.
Habt ihr eigentlich schon alle meine, meine neue Katze gesehen?
Da ist sie.
Auch wenn der Name merkwürdig ist.
Sie heißt Chico und ist, ist eine Katze.
Weiß nicht, warum man, warum man seine, seine Katze Chico nennt anstatt Chica, aber ist so.
Und, aber die hört da drauf.
Das hab ich noch nie gesehen.
Die anderen haben sich für ihren Namen überhaupt nicht interessiert.
Kaum sagst du bei Chico, Chico, geht sofort das Ohr hoch, so nach dem Motto, was ist, gibt's was?
Und ich komm heute mit dem Chat echt nicht hinterher.
Das ist der Wahnsinn.
Das ist nicht, ist, ist, ist nicht möglich gerade.
Ähm, wie krieg ich meine beiden Rechner dazu, dass ich von meinem Hauptrechner die zweite Festplatte vom zweiten Rechner über den Explorer zuge...
Einfach rechts draufklicken und einen Scheren andrücken.
Das ist, äh, um ehrlich zu sein, ist das...
Aber mit Zugstories.
So, mal gucken.
Bietet sich auch mal wieder an.
Also, falls ich irgendwas überlese, müsst ihr auf jeden Fall AdWoblos schreiben, weil ich seh das nicht.
Wann kommt der XADM-Anal-Penetrierer zurück?
Ach, weiß ich nicht.
Das war übelst cringe.
Mach mal wieder IT-Mythen.
Ne, das hab ich geplant.
Kennst du...
...Gear Thunderlord?
Nö.
Sagt mir gar nix.
Ich kenne extrem viele Leute auf YouTube nicht mehr.
Also, jedes Mal, wenn ich, wenn ich, äh, YouTube aufmache, krieg ich Videos von jemand Neuem empfohlen, der 500.000 plus abgibt.
Von dem ich im Leben noch nix gehört hab.
Was ist mit Under Serial?
Den gibt's noch.
Ähm...
Ich würd auch gerne an deiner Tür kratzen.
Minigun Michi 2.0
hat subscribt Twitch Prime.
Dankeschön.
Mach was mit Krieger.
Macht der noch überhaupt was?
Der taucht doch jetzt überall.
Auf der Welt rum.
Was hätte die?
Netzfreigabe für eine Bandbreite.
Kann man so Videos in Vegas bearbeiten?
Ja, geht.
Das hängt davon ab, wie schnell dein Netzwerk ist.
Hast du mal überlegt, Overwatch mit Role Queue wieder zu zocken?
Ja.
Hab ich sogar gemacht auf dem PTR.
Wir brauchen mehr Battlefield 3 Gameplay.
Battlefield 3 ist relativ tot.
Es gibt auf dem PC noch ein paar Dämmer, wenn Peak Rush Server...
Ansonsten...
Muss ich mal gucken.
Fucking Pock.
Gechillt im Bett Videos schneiden.
Kann man das am Tablet?
Und...
Dual mit Katja Grasawitze.
Genau.
Das ist natürlich die erste Dual-Partnerin, die ich mir vorstelle, wenn ich sage, ich muss mit jemand anderem was aufnehmen.
Ich habe jetzt nicht irgendwie an Leute gedacht, die Gaming Sachen machen, sondern das erste, woran ich gedacht habe, war natürlich Katja Grasawitze.
Ich weiß gar nicht...
Ich könnte den Namen noch nehmen, aber ich weiß nicht mal, wie man den Namen richtig ausspricht.
Ich fände es super, wenn du ein Laberstells-Video machen würdest.
Ja, da werde ich bestimmt noch genug machen.
Wir vermissen dich, Max.
Der Charme und die Qualität deiner Videos ist immer noch top.
Ups.
Irgendwie habe ich es gerade nicht ausgeblendet.
Irgendwie da Zug-Stories.
Ich werde bestimmt mal irgendwas zum Zug erzählen, aber es ist jetzt ja nicht so, dass jeden Tag irgendwas total Spannendes im Zug passiert.
Ich hatte übrigens noch eine gute...
Eine gute Video-Idee.
Ich wollte so ein paar Sachen erzählen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie ich das nennen soll.
Irgendwie Horror-Stories aus dem Support kann ich es nicht nennen, weil es ist nicht wirklich Support.
Wo ich ein paar abgedrehte Sachen erzähle, die ich so die letzten 12, 13 Jahre IT-mäßig erlebt habe.
Weil da waren schon ein paar ziemlich beknackte Sachen drin.
Und ich meine jetzt nicht, dass ich meine Schuhe hinterm Rack trockne, sondern wirklich ziemlich bescheuerte Sachen.
Max, alles fit?
Ja, alles.
Huge fit.
Big brain fit.
Deshalb habe ich mir die Dark Edition vorbestellt.
Ich würde mir nie was vorbestellen mehr.
Ich verstehe das nicht.
Muss ich euch mal fragen.
Also, Chat.
Ja?
Ja.
Cute, cute Chat.
Bestellt ihr euch Games vor?
Und wenn ja, warum bestellt ihr euch Games vor?
Ich persönlich bin der Meinung, Games vorbestellen bringt nichts.
Weil das, was man...
Also man bekommt das gleiche Game, wenn es raus ist.
Und heute ist es ja auch so, ich muss nichts vorbestellen.
Weil ich kann es einfach downloaden am Tag des Releases.
Die einzige Sache, wenn irgendjemand was vorbestellt, vielleicht wenn er irgendwie Call of Duty auf der Konsole zwei Tage früher spielen will, weil er Glück hat, aber es lohnt sich eigentlich nicht.
Es lohnt sich aktuell überhaupt nicht mehr, was vorzubestellen.
Das Einzige, was ich mir noch vorstellen könnte, was vorzubestellen, ist, wenn es irgendwie eine Super Collectors Special Extreme Edition ist.
Solange es nicht so übertrieben ist wie bei Watch Dogs, falls sich da noch einer dran erinnern kann.
Ich meine, guckt euch die Tabellenliste von Watch...
Die Editions an, die Watch Dogs hatte.
Das ist kein Witz.
So viele Versionen, so viele unterschiedliche Versionen von Watch Dogs 1 gab es.
Das ist aber auch die schlimmsten Ausmaße, die ich da je gesehen habe von.
Also wenn es jetzt, sagen wir mal, die bringen jetzt irgendwie...
Ich weiß nicht, sagen wir mal, sie würden jetzt irgendwie Max Payne 4 oder so rausbringen, was ja eines meiner absolut Lieblings-Spieleserien ist.
Und man kann auch sagen, es wäre wieder von Remedy in Max Payne 4.
Und so bringen irgendwie eine Super Special Collectors Edition raus mit irgendwie Figuren aus Teil 1, 2, 3, 4 oder so.
Und ich sage, oh, das sieht so geil aus und es gibt da irgendwie limitiert was von...
Okay, dann würde ich es vorbestellen, aber dann würde ich ja nicht wirklich das Game vorbestellen, sondern eigentlich hauptsächlich den Content.
Von der Special Edition.
Aber ansonsten finde ich, lohnt sich vorbestellen nicht.
Verstehe keinen Sinn.
Und selbst so Sachen wie Nintendo-Spiele, die ja, sagen wir mal, selten die Fans wirklich enttäuschen.
Ja, Nintendo ist ja da recht konstant.
Also sprich, wenn ein neues Zelda kommt und du bist Zelda-Fan, kannst du eigentlich Zelda vorbestellen.
Gibt nichts, was dagegen spricht.
Aber selbst da lohnt es sich nicht.
Weil du kannst das Spiel einfach am Release-Tag runterladen.
Also wozu, wozu, wozu?
Ich finde das lohnt sich nicht.
Ähm, genau.
So viel zu so viel vorbestellen.
Zu dem ersten Video waren sehr viele Comments dabei, die sich gefreut haben, dass ich wieder am Start bin.
Wie gesagt, das freut mich auch immer, wenn ich das sehe.
Obwohl ich keine Subs verpasst habe.
Nope, habe ich nicht.
Ähm...
Manchmal registrieren Schüsse nicht.
Du warst halt zweimal 100% neben dem Spieler.
Das ist ja schon lustig, wenn man eigentlich das Spiel...
Ich glaube nicht, dass ich...
Ich weiß, welche Szene er meint, aber ich war nicht neben dem Spieler.
Guckt es euch mal an.
Ich zeige euch mal die Szene, die er meint.
Hat er es am Anfang?
Ja, passt mal auf.
Sagt mal, ob ich daneben war oder nicht.
Jetzt ernsthaft.
Guckt euch das mal an und sagt, ich bin daneben.
Ich bin voll drauf und jetzt...
Schuss.
Das ist ja...
Ich ziehe das ja nicht nach oben.
Das ist ja der Recoil von der Waffe.
Das ist ja der Recoil von der Waffe, der so springt.
Guckt mal.
Das ist voll drauf.
Bam.
Und jetzt zweiter Schuss, zweiter Schuss.
Zweiter Schuss, Achtung.
Na gut.
Der zweite Schuss war gegen die Brüstung.
Das lasse ich mir gefallen.
Weil selbst der zweite Schuss...
Naja, gut.
Machen wir kurz Slow-Mo rein.
Okay, Leute, wir gucken uns das jetzt an.
Wir gucken uns das jetzt an.
Slow-Mo. Geht das überhaupt?
Playback-Speed.
0,5.
Moment, das ist der falsche Schuss.
Sie haben auf mich gesagt,
wir haben mal welche nachgepatcht.
Das klingt ein bisschen unanständig, oder?
So, als ist gerade irgendwie
Cup of Pride unterm Tisch am Start oder so.
So, passt mal auf jetzt.
Das ist nicht verzogen.
Das ist voll drauf.
Guckt, das ist voll drauf.
Bam.
Machen wir mal ein Frame-by-Frame-Index.
Kann man das überhaupt übertreiben?
Mehr geht ja auch gar nicht.
Custom.
Weniger geht nicht.
Ein Pixel zu weit vom Kopf.
Ja, weil die Call of Duty-Konsolen-Hitboxen
auch so bekannt dafür sind, dass die
pixel-pixel-genau sind.
Also ich behaupte immer noch, das war drauf.
Wir müssen es jetzt aber auch nicht
überanalysieren, ja.
Die guten Spiele sind in den Key-Stores
teurer als Vorwies.
Das stimmt.
Auf eh nix mehr über Key-Stores.
Ich hab ja...
Jetzt kann ich das sagen.
Ich hab ja keine vertraglichen Verpflichtungen mehr dafür.
Ich hab ja G2A nie promotet,
weil ich G2A irgendwie so geil fand
oder von dem Business-Modell überzeugt war.
Der einzige Grund, warum ich G2A
promotet hab,
ist, weil sie
ziemlich viel Kohle bezahlt haben.
Pro Monat.
Warum dieser Name hier auf Twitch
und nicht MaxFPS?
Zwei Gründe.
Erster Grund, weil ich den Account erstellt hab,
als ich überhaupt nicht dran gedacht hab,
selbst zu streamen.
Ich wollte nicht, dass ich erkannt werde,
wenn ich in anderen Streams dämliches Zeug spamme.
Das war so der erste Grund.
Und der zweite Grund ist, warum ich dabei geblieben bin.
Ich mein, ich könnte mich immer noch umbenennen, ja.
Ich hab den Renames... Geht.
Ich hab sogar den MaxFPS-Account.
Ich könnte mich umbenennen.
Aber ich find's eigentlich ganz gut,
weil es kommen manchmal
richtige Deppen rüber.
Weil es kommen manchmal richtige Deppen rüber.
Die mich irgendwann mal
vor Jahren geguckt haben
und mich schon immer mal flamen wollten,
tauchen dann hier im Chat auf.
Und ich könnte mir vorstellen,
wenn ich hier heiß wie auf YouTube,
gibt's davon noch mehr.
So rum ist mir's lieber.
So rum kommen jetzt nämlich hauptsächlich die Leute,
die's interessiert.
Die noch aktiv am Start sind.
Da kommt die Wahrheit ans Licht, ja.
Naja, ganz ehrlich.
Jetzt mal, wie hätte der Kaboom gesagt?
Hand aufs Herz.
Denkt irgendjemand wirklich,
Leute promoten Keyshops
oder solche Läden,
weil sie davon innerlich voll überzeugt sind?
Weil sie davon innerlich voll überzeugt sind?
Oder ist es nicht bei allen irgendwie die Kohle?
Also bei mir war's die Kohle,
das kann ich sagen.
Woher hast du die Emote-Sound-Einplanung?
Gibt's da Soundports oder sowas?
Das hab ich selbst programmiert.
Hier, da.
Da ist es, ja.
Da ist...
Da ist das Memeboard.
Das ist ne ASP.net Core-Anwendung
mit WPF für das Overlay.
Ich hab's selbst gebastelt.
Easy...
Wie viel hat G2A dir bezahlt?
Weiß nicht, ob ich das jetzt groß an die Glocke hängen soll.
Wobei, ich scheiß drauf.
Ich hab's schon mal erzählt.
Ähm, lass mal kurz in mich gehen.
Ich bin mir nicht mehr ganz sicher,
was ich zum Schluss gekriegt hab.
Ich hab ja mit denen auch ein paar Mal hin und her verhandelt.
Ich sag mal so,
ungefähr 1000 Euro im Monat.
So über den Daumen gepeilt.
Plus, minus Affiliate.
Ungefähr.
So im Dreh.
Und das war für mich halt damals ein ziemlich gutes Angebot, ja.
Und ich hab gesagt, gut.
Dafür mach ich auch Sellout und erzähl ihr seid die geilsten.
Ist mir doch wurscht.
Ja, das finde ich,
Matt, das finde ich auch übertrieben.
Er schreibt hier grad,
inzwischen erzählen die YouTuber ja zwei Minuten lang davon,
wie Produkt ihr Leben verändert hat
und wie sie nie wieder ohne auskommen.
Ich finde es teilweise auch extrem.
Also,
total übertrieben,
was bei manchen Promotion-Geschichten abgeht.
Es gibt aber auch Hersteller,
die haben da keinen Bock drauf, ne.
Mario Kart für iOS vorbestellt.
Stimmt, kommt ja demnächst auch.
Hat es Scheine oder Münzen geregnet?
Ich hab's ja grad gesagt.
Schau mal ein altes Video vom Kaboom.
Können wir irgendwann,
können wir am Wochenende machen?
Wir machen am Wochenende immer sonntags einen Aufwach-Stream so ab.
Ja, wir haben schon um 8 gestartet,
aber hauptsächlich so um halb 9, halb 10 rum.
Teilweise bis 13, 14 Uhr.
Da gucken wir uns immer noch ein paar Videos an
und aktuelle Sachen.
Da können wir uns auch mal ein Kaboom-Video angucken.
Inwiefern sind Key-Seiten fragwürdig?
Es ist fragwürdig, woher die Keys kommen.
Das ist so ein bisschen,
so ein bisschen wie die Läden,
die die Microsoft- oder Windows-Keys für 1,50 verkaufen.
Wobei, nee, kann man nicht vergleichen.
Bei den Microsoft-Keys sind es auf jeden Fall
quasi ordentlich ausgestellte,
für diesen Zweck, Keys.
Key-Seiten-Keys sind das teilweise Promotion-Keys,
die irgendwo geleakt wurden
oder vermeintliche, vermeintliche
Keys für vermeintliche YouTuber, Streamer oder sonst was.
Da wird getrickst ohne Ende.
Mich würde nicht wundern, wenn da manche irgendwie,
manche Code-Packs von irgendeinem LKW geklaut werden oder so.
Würde mich alles nicht wundern.
Allerdings, man kann den Key-Shops
auch nicht den kompletten Vorwurf machen,
weil zumindest bei G2A ist es so,
dass es ein Marketplace ist, also sprich,
nicht G2A, die die fragwürdigen Keys verkauft,
sondern Seller.
Allerdings weiß das G2A.
Also es kann mir keiner erzählen,
dass das G2A nicht weiß.
Was es nicht weniger fragwürdig macht, ne?
Wir machen das jetzt,
wir müssen das jetzt hier wie I Love Cookies machen,
jetzt einfach hier 10k beim Pokern ausgeben.
Da ist doch jetzt krasser, krasser,
der Fedor, Fedorz,
da ist doch jetzt krasser, ähm,
Pokerman habe ich, habe ich,
irgendwo, ich glaube,
der Emco hat mir das glaube ich erzählt, ne?
Das ist voll krasser Poker.
Gut.
Progon fragt, setze gerade mein Laptop für Studium auf
und bin mir unsicher, auf welches Betriebssystem ich setzen soll.
Linux fürs Programmieren oder Windows,
weil du dafür auch alles bekommst.
Ganz einfach.
Das ist super einfach.
Mach so wie ich, installiere dir Windows
und installiere dir eine Linux-VM.
Ganz einfach.
Vielleicht geht's jetzt.
Ach man, warum, warum ist das kaputt?
Warum habe ich mein Programm geschrottet?
Du hast Kreditkartenbetrug vergessen.
Wenn's um das, wenn's um Keyshops geht, auch das, ja.
Hauptsächlich wahrscheinlich sogar das,
bei irgendwelchen Keyshop-Resellern.
Nee, der ist heute rausgeflogen, keine Ahnung,
habe ich nicht verfolgt, aber
ich weiß noch, dass das jetzt der krasse Pokerman ist.
Fedor hat mit Poker circa eine Million verdient.
Dazu kann man sagen, easy money, easy life.
Wobei man ja nie weiß, ob das, ob das alles so stimmt immer, ne?
Also bei, generell bei Werbung für irgendwelche Glücksspiel-Sachen
wäre ich, wäre ich, ich weiß, dass Poker nicht
reines Glücksspiel in Form von, ähm,
zumindest wenn man, ähm,
mit ein bisschen Plan und über längere Zeit macht,
nicht vergleichbar ist mit dem Druck auf dem Automat rum,
aber bei allen, die quasi hypen,
dass sie mit, äh, mit irgendeiner Form von Glücksspiel
Millionär, Reich, sonst was geworden sind,
da wäre ich immer skeptisch.
Moin, denkst du ein Informatikstudium nach der Physi-Ausbildung macht Sinn
oder kommt man weiter, wenn man die Zeiten, Zertifikate und Berufserfahrung steckt?
Zertifikate kommt auf den Laden an, ich finde Zertifikate sinnlos.
Berufserfahrung ist wichtig, ähm,
und, äh, es ist vor allem wichtig,
dass du dich in einem Bereich auskennst,
der ordentlich Kohle bringt.
Also wenn du, wenn du ein bisschen Windows-Oberfläche klicken kannst,
ist das ganz nett, werden auch Leute gesucht, aber
die wahnsinns, äh, Bezahlung wirst du dafür nicht kriegen.
Kommt ein bisschen drauf an, ja.
Und die, äh, die hauptsächliche Frage ist eigentlich eher,
ob dir das, das liegt, also ob du beispielsweise auf, auf
analytische Sachen stehst, ob du auf
Mathe stehst, ob du, ähm, ja, sowas.
Dann ist es sicherlich nicht verkehrt, wenn du Spaß dran hast
oder dich dafür interessierst, das mal zu probieren mit dem Studium.
Halbe Kotzszene nach Black Ops 2 zu Lifestyle und Casino gewechselt.
Jaja.
Deswegen verfolge ich da auch kaum noch einen.
Hier gibt's den Weg von Windows 32 Spiele auf 64 Spiele.
Ne, glaub nicht.
Was ist mit dem Linux-Subsystem von Windows?
Ist auf einem guten Weg, fehlt noch einiges.
Vor allem kein ordentliches Terminal unter Windows.
War das nicht viel noch mit den Fast Passes?
Dazu sag ich nix.
Ich kenn die umfangreichere Story davon.
Ich war ja, ich war ja live dabei.
Ähm, da sag ich nix zu.
Ich kann nur sagen, es ist nicht unbedingt alles immer so,
wie's auf den ersten Blick aussieht.
Ist transparent, okay.
Weiß.
Okay.
Ähm.
Na, komm, komm, komm, komm.
Ich hab den Chat aufgeholt.
Gut, ähm.
Boah, Face, keine Ahnung, zu.
Ich glaub, im ersten Video kam jetzt nicht mehr so viel Interessantes,
außer halt, wie gesagt, die ganze Geschichte mit, dass die Leute freuen.
Hab ich schon oft gesagt, freut mich auch immer, wenn das einer schreibt.
Der beste Gewichte des Schusses bleibt bei der AK Headshot von CSGO.
Dieses Geräusch.
So, bling.
Nee, bling, bling war Overwatch.
Fuck, was macht, was macht CS nochmal?
Overwatch hat bling gemacht.
CS macht so dieses tsch.
Ha?
Genau.
Tsch.
Doch, das da macht's.
Viel zu lange Pause und zu wenig Videos von dir für neue Abos.
FeelsBatman.
Die Map einfach AWP India geklaut.
AWP India?
Ist das der Microsoft-Supporter CS spielt, oder was?
Nee.
Ja, sieht tatsächlich ähnlich aus.
Die ganzen MW2-2-on-2-Maps waren richtig schlecht.
Hast du Tipps für die IHK-Abschlussprüfung, Anwendungsentwicklung?
Ja.
Einfach alte Abschlussprüfung angucken. Easy.
Die IHK-Abschlussprüfung kann jeder schaffen.
Jeder.
Sogar jeder, der die Ausbildung nicht gemacht hat, kann die IHK-Abschlussprüfung schaffen.
Die IHK-Abschlussprüfung ist eigentlich, wenn man's genau nimmt, kein, äh, irgendwie Qualitätsmerkmal.
Ich würd mich eher wundern, wenn die Leute zu gut abgeschnitten haben.
Dass die zu sehr, zu sehr IHK-Style denken und man damit nichts anfangen kann.
Das Waffengefühl ist ähnlich zu Battlefield 3.
Oh, ich weiß nicht.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich finde, die Waffen haben sich in Battlefield 3 eigentlich relativ leicht angefühlt.
Die Waffen in MW, in dem neuen Modern Warfare fühlen sich schwer an.
Was ist intelligentes Nachlassen? Gute Frage, wollt ich auch grad fragen.
Was ist intelligentes Nachladen?
Du meinst, dass man schneller nachlädt, wenn man leer geschossen hat, oder was?
Äh, langsamer nachlädt, wenn man leer geschossen hat?
Investierst du dein Geld in Immobilien oder Aktien oder so?
Also alle diese ganzen Wirtschaftsgeschichten sind wirklich nicht meins.
Allerdings muss ich dazu sagen, ähm, ich kann mir auch nicht mit angucken, dass irgendwie mein Geld da rumgammelt und nichts passiert.
In letzter Zeit habe ich ein bisschen Geld, also nicht wirklich, man kann es eigentlich nicht investiert nennen.
Ich habe ein paar Leuten Geld geliehen zu ganz guten Zinsen.
Also wie nennt man das sowas? Privatdarlehen, Privatkredit oder so.
Aber mit Vertrag und allem, was dazu gehört.
Und die ersten zwei Sachen sind auch schon zurückbezahlt, das hat sich gelohnt.
Ich war fast schon ein bisschen...
Fast schon ein bisschen, ähm, fast schon ein bisschen schlechtes Gewissen bei dem Zinssatz beim ersten, ne?
Magst du mir den Baseballschläger beim Geld abtreiben?
Ne, ich mach das anders.
Ähm, wir machen einen Vertrag und wenn sich beispielsweise einer ein Auto kauft,
was bei dem einen, aber einen wollte ich gebraucht, das Auto kaufen,
ähm, krieg ich halt den Schein vom Auto, bis es abbezahlt ist.
Ich mein, klar, ich mach das auch nur mit Leuten, die ich halt kenne.
Es ist mit Sicherheit nicht der weise als letzter Schluss irgendwie,
aber für alles andere bin ich zu...
Warum sollten die Leute zu dir gehen und nicht zur Bank,
vielleicht zum Beispiel, weil sie einen Schuhvereintrag haben?
Der eine hatte einen Schuhvereintrag von nem, von nem Mobilfunkanbieter,
der wollte sich Geld leihen, das ist jetzt nicht ausgedacht, ja?
Muss man nämlich davor sagen, weil das so übertrieben viel ist.
Nicht ausgedacht, wollte er zur Bank, hat gesagt, ich brauch Geld für ein Auto,
Bank hat gesagt, nee, gibt's nicht.
Da ist er zu nem anderen Typ gegangen, der halt auch an Leute, die von der Bank nichts kriegen,
und der wollte über drei Jahre, haltet euch fest,
FÜMMUNSIBZIG PROZENT.
Also das ist wahrscheinlich schon illegal.
Über drei Jahre, FÜMMUNSIBZIG PROZENT.
Da hab ich halt gesagt, bei mir ist es billiger.
Aber ich mach das nur mit Leuten, die ich kenne, also ich verleihe keinem...
Nee, ich verleihe jetzt nicht irgendwie groß Kohle an random Leute aus dem Chat,
auch nicht, weil's Q-Chat ist.
Äh, Doobie Day, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön.
Nee, das ist nicht illegal, solange ich den Kram versteuer, ist da nix illegal.
Ach, du meinst die 75%?
Nee, ich glaube noch nicht.
Ich hab das jetzt nur gesagt mit dem Illegal.
Ich bin mir gar nicht mal so sicher, ob das illegal ist.
Wenn das vorher klar ist, wenn das allen Beteiligten klar ist,
und man sich im Vollbesitz seiner geistigen Kräfte befindet und das unterschreibt,
glaub ich nicht, dass das illegal ist.
Es ist ja auch nicht verboten, Scheiße zu verkaufen,
wenn ich Leute finde, die Scheiße kaufen.
Sixcore.de, moin.
Es gibt Leute, die verkaufen OpenOffice, äh LibreOffice.
Gibt's es?
Es gibt Leute, die kaufen das.
Pass mal auf.
Falls ihr mir das nicht glaubt, Ebay.
Ups.
Weiß nicht, was ich da für ein Ebay-Adresse hatte.
Ich lass es mal lieber.
Hier.
LibreOffice.
Ah, LibreOffice, 2€.
LibreOffice, 5€.
LibreOffice, 6 Starter, 10€.
Sag doch.
15€, weil's auf nem USB-Stick ist.
Für 15€ kriegst du in China 20 USB-Sticks.
Äh, NoshiBoshi, mach mal Ausrufezeichen Beruf.
Die Frage kommt nämlich öfters.
Ich hab das schon mal versucht zu erklären.
Steigt doch ins Gamer-Badewasser-Geschäft ein.
Ich hab gehört, Belle Delphine wurde gebannt.
Auf Instagram.
Ist das so? Stimmt das?
Ich will jetzt nicht auf die Seite gucken, weil MonkaTos...
Übrigens, ich hätte noch ein Thema am Ende.
So zum Outro.
Aber es dauert noch.
Wir haben noch massig Zeit.
Wo ich mich nochmal richtig...
Wo ich mich nochmal ein bisschen aufregen kann drüber.
Nacho Libre, 2 Monate.
Nice, dankeschön.
Gerade rechnerneu aufgesetzt.
So ein geiles Gefühl.
Weiß ich...
Ich...
Weiß ich nicht.
Also, ich finde nicht.
Da muss man immer so viel Zeug neu einrichten.
Ich hab mein Windows seit 5 Jahren nicht mehr neu installiert.
Irgendwie in dem Dreh.
Ewig nicht mehr.
Nee, stimmt nicht.
Auf die...
Auf die M2 SSD hab ich's neu installiert vor 3 Jahren.
Übrigens, nice.
263 Leute.
Huge.
Ähm...
Was...
Blöde Frage.
Wer ist denn alles von YouTube hier?
Okay, viele.
Viele.
Ja, weil es ist schon interessant.
Ich meine...
Ähm...
Normalerweise...
Je nach...
je nach...
je nach Thema.
Das höchste was ich mal hatte an Zuschauern, war so glaube ich um die 300 bei den Gamescom
Sachen.
Und ansonsten ist es irgendwie so maximal 180 so rum.
Meinte ich, ich soll ab und zu mal ein paar Ankündigungen auf YouTube posten?
Ich mein...
Ich meine, ich werde nicht jeden Stream ankündigen, vor allem wenn es irgendein Programmier-Stream ist oder so, das werden die meisten Leute auf YouTube nicht interessieren, aber wenn wir irgendwas machen, was die Leute auf YouTube interessieren könnte, jetzt gehen die Subs, nee, die Follower gehen jetzt ab, Follower-Spam, oh, ich habe was übersehen, der Hummerhans hat abonniert, habe ich das übersehen, oder habe ich den Hummerhans schon vorgelesen?
Hummerhans, bist du noch am Start? Extra für den Hummerhans, hast du nicht, oh, dafür schrumpft der Chat-IQ jetzt, oh, viels Batman, Hummerhans, kurze IT-Frage, mein Notebook hat einen Kern permanent zu 100% ausgelastet, im Idle, das kann nicht Idle sein, egal, habe Windows mehrmals 19, aber es geht nicht weg, hast du Windows 9 installiert von der CD vom Hersteller?
Wenn du es von der CD vom Hersteller hast, lad den...
...ein ordentliches ISO runter und installiere nochmal neu, nicht viels Batman, sondern viels Bad-Man, komplett neu formatiert, ja, gute Frage, dann weiß ich es auch nicht, also im ersten Video waren nicht so viele interessante Comments drin, aber es hat mich motiviert, dass so viele Leute sich gefreut haben, dass ich wieder am Start bin, äh, das finde ich auch, also dieser 2 vs. 2 Modus wirkt ein bisschen wie, als wollen sie auf, ähm, als wollen sie ein bisschen auf Rainbow Six machen,
naja, Hummerhans, ich hab das nicht zu ernst genommen, keine Sorge, im Task-Manager steht nur System, es könnte sein, dass Windows erstmal ewig lange updatet, das macht Windows ganz gerne mal, hast du das mal ein bisschen stehen lassen, ob das nicht weggeht nach einer Zeit?
Wo ist das Intro? Intros sind auf YouTube nicht mehr angesagt, zumindest nicht Intros ganz vorne, heute macht man entweder, ähm, ein bisschen Preview und Intro, oder man scheißt aufs Intro und...
labert gleich los, weil gerade die ersten 10 Sekunden sind halt heutzutage enorm wichtig, weil halt keiner mehr wirklich lange Videos guckt, also, also keiner, keiner wirklich, ähm, die große Aufmerksamkeit hat für, Leute machen das an, und wenn du nicht die ersten 20, 30 Sekunden was sagst, was die Leute geil finden, machen die meisten aus.
Der Rückstoß in Modern Warfare ist bei einigen Waffen eben nicht, nicht ohne, ja.
Okay, kann ich nicht einschätzen, aber ich glaube an den Klang der Waffen aus Bad Company 2 mit Wartapes kommt kein Spiel in nächster Zeit, oder je ran, bester, bester Klang überhaupt.
Sollte nicht 3 Stunden dauern, nee, nee, nee, Noah, sollte es, sollte es nicht.
Kannst du mal von Hand Windows-Update machen, nach dem Neuinstallieren?
Mach es von Hand Windows-Update an, lass ich mal aufs zum Neuesten aktualisieren, und mach mal, falls die Probleme weiter bestehen.
Da hat ihr mal vom Hersteller, ähm, die, die, die, die, das, das, den ihr jeweiliges Service-Tool oder was sie da haben runter, und mach mal BIOS-Update.
Oder, ist ja kein BIOS mehr, ist ja EFI-Update.
Wusstet ihr eigentlich, das aktuelle EFI, also die aktuellen UEFI, ähm, Sachen, die ihr auf dem Mainboard habt, was da alles drin ist?
Die Dinger haben mittlerweile einen kompletten USB-Stack, einen kompletten TCP-Stack, teilweise einen kompletten Bluetooth-Stack, ähm,
und was weiß ich noch?
Alles.
So ein EFI ist mittlerweile, glaube ich, irgendwie, was?
Was habe ich letztens gelesen?
An die eine Million Codes heilen?
Ich meine, wer hat sich nicht schon immer mal gewundert und gesagt, früher, als er in diesem alten BIOS war, mit dem blauen Hintergrund,
wer hat da nicht damals schon immer gesagt, Alter, hätte ich jetzt mal einen TCP-Stack im BIOS?
Ach so, das ist, na Moment, wenn das ein HP, wenn das ein fertiger HP oben ist, dann sollte sowas wirklich nicht passieren.
Ey, Max, dass es dich noch gibt.
Ja, mich gibt's auf Twitch, auf Twitch gibt's mich schon zwei Jahre und sogar relativ regelmäßig.
Aber auf YouTube in letzter Zeit wenig, da hast du recht.
Langzeit-Motivation, ja, Langzeit-Motivation ist der Modern Warfare 2.2-Modus auf jeden Fall nicht.
Im ersten, ich skipp mal zum zweiten Video.
Warum macht man die ins UEFI eigentlich keinen Windows-Linux-Downloader rein?
Dann bräuchte man keine Bootstix mehr.
Keine Ahnung.
Auf die Idee ist noch keiner gekommen.
Next, next level.
Play.
Kann man dann nicht über den TCP-Stack auch ein BIOS-Update machen?
Ja, ja, klar.
Mir ist schon klar, warum da Bluetooth, USB und TCP-IP drin sind.
Logisch.
Das ist, dass alle Einbegabegeräte im BIOS funktionieren.
Keiner hat mehr Bock, eine PS2-Tastatur anzuschließen, nur fürs BIOS.
Oder eine All-USB-Tastatur.
Nein, vorbei.
Nichts USB.
Will keiner PS2.
Und es wird auch keiner mehr mit Diskette ein BIOS-Update machen.
Schon klar.
Die Leute wollen ins BIOS.
Es will auch keiner mehr eine 640x480 Auflösung im BIOS haben.
Die Leute wollen da heute am besten noch Maus-Support und alles.
Kennst du dich mit Routern aus?
Ah, sorry.
Router.
Ja.
Wir haben ja viele Cisco-Fans im Chat, das weiß ich ja.
Aber ich persönlich mag immer noch eher die Aussprache Router.
Kennst du dich mit Routern aus?
Das Wort von einer Fritzbox.
7, 3, 6, 2...
U, S, L auf eine 4,000, 4,000, 4,000, 4,000 Umstände habe eine 500er L...
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß noch nicht mal, was die Dinge unterscheidet überhaupt.
Aber ja, ich kenn mich mit Routern aus, aber ich hab's am Anfang gesagt.
Eine Fritzbox ist ein ziemlich schlechter Router.
Eine Fritzbox ist ein sehr gutes Multifunktionsgerät.
Die Routing-Funktionen von einer Fritzbox sind doch äußerst rudimentär.
Aber ich weiß, die meisten Leute sagen Router.
Router.
Was die coolen Leute sagen.
Routimentär, genau.
Hast du eigentlich noch was mit den alten YouTube-Hasen wie Kabum, Commander Krieger und dem Friseur zu nennen?
Na, mit dem Friseur E.
Mit dem Friseur E, den kenn ich auch schon vorher.
Mit dem Kabum ganz, ganz selten.
Mit dem Krieger gar nicht mehr.
Letztens hast du mit dem M-Com wieder gelabert.
Ne, mit dem M-Com.
Alter M-Core.
Ich mein...
Ich mein nicht M-Com.
Pflegehenne M-Com.
Ähm.
Das fand ich übrigens sehr nice, falls du noch da bist.
Wir sollen auf jeden Fall was aufnehmen.
Wieder mal.
Jetzt demnächst, solange ich noch Motivation hab.
Weißt du, warum Kabum nichts mehr bringt?
Das fragt er sich selbst.
Also, so wirklich abgeschlossen hat er eigentlich nie mit dem YouTube-Thema, ja.
Aber, also ich glaube, es ist so ein bisschen...
Der wird einfach...
... mit seinem eigenen Anspruch an die Videoqualität...
... nicht so richtig gerecht.
Ob Max damals auf dem Abotreffen von Commander Krieger war?
Nö.
I buy den...
Oh ne, einfach nur buy den.
Ja, danach gab's noch zwei, drei Videos.
Mit Tio oder Rheinfelswelle?
Ah, mit dem Tio hab ich vor...
Boah, vor einer ganzen Weile mal...
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob wir gelabert haben oder was.
Ob wir mal kurz geschrieben haben.
Aber nicht wirklich, ne.
Wie findest du Black Desert?
Es ist nicht mein Game.
Ich weiß, der Fabian grindet das rauf und runter, also der Friseur, aber es ist nicht mein Game.
Herr Kabuma mit den Videos einer Zeit voraus.
Ich finde, es gibt heute keine Videos in dieser Richtung.
Es gibt zwar viel, viel mehr Videos, die gut editiert sind.
Und viel, viel mehr Videos, die auch mehr, mehr, wie sagt man so, Production Value haben, ja.
Aber Production Value plus kompetenter Inhalt in der Tiefe gibt's eigentlich nicht.
Die Maps sehen aus wie billige Steam Workshop.
Für CS.
Ja, genau das denke ich über die aktuellen Modern Warfare Maps auch.
Das mit den Maps ist schon ein kleines Problem.
Gerade in einem solchen Modus würden sich lustige Gimmicks anbieten.
Schalter, Falltür oder...
Ja, finde ich auch.
Bisschen taktischer könnte man das Ganze machen.
Vermiss mega die Black Ops 1 Zeiten.
Karten wie Summit, Jungle, äh, äh, weiblich, männlich, divers, Hanoi, etc.
Jo.
Das war schon nice.
Hörst du immer noch Metal?
Und falls ja, welche Bands hörst du am liebsten?
Ja, klar, immer noch.
Also aktuell, was ich, was ich extrem nice finde, ist, ähm, ist fast schon so ein, wie, nicht wirklich gehypt.
Die sind eigentlich ziemlich bekannt.
Was ich übelst, was mir übelst gut fällt, ist, ähm, das hier.
Das finde, das gefällt mir übelst gut.
Huge nice.
Es ist halt Power Metal, ja.
Ja, das finde ich cool.
Also vor allem dieses Album.
Das hat wirklich Ohrwurm nach Ohrwurm.
Und ist bei Amazon Unlimited Music dabei.
Power Metal Beste.
Wollen wir uns mal eins anhören nebenbei?
Oder verschrecke ich, oder verschrecke ich euch mit, mit Power Metal?
Ha, ha.
Okay.
Gucken wir mal, ob es auf YouTube was gibt.
So in die Richtung wie Dragon Force.
Ja, genau.
Genau.
Wir gucken uns aber nicht das Video an.
Übelste Headbanging Action.
Übelst nice.
Also ist genau mein Geschmack.
Also, der, der Refrain ist auch übelst nice.
Achtet mal.
Ja.
Ja, kann ich nur empfehlen, Leute.
Kann ich nur empfehlen.
Beste.
Erstmal Musikkontrast hier.
Wie findest du Rammstein? Ist nicht meins.
Ich finde auch die Rammstein Texte übelst äh...
cringe teilweise.
Nicht so sehr von der Aussage, die sie manchmal haben.
Das ist halt absichtlich, dass sie da ein bisschen kontroverse Dinge erzählen.
Aber wie die, wie die, sagen wir mal, gedichtet sind, die, die, äh, Rammstein Texte.
Das ist, das, das, da zieht sich, wie auch immer, die Sachen zusammen, ne?
Du musst direkt Hammerfall, äh, Hammerfall Last Man Standing haben.
Das ist auch nice, ja.
Hammerfall kann man auch empfehlen.
Wie findest du Sabaton? Auch gut.
Wobei, wobei Sabaton wenig mit Ayaya zu tun hat, ne?
Eigentlich Null.
Sabaton ist eigentlich eher was für, ähm, zweite Weltkriegsshooter.
Da wird, da passt das gut.
Was ist das Zelda-Lesezeichen in der Seite?
Ah, das ist der Zelda, ähm, äh, 20, 20 Jahre, 20 Jahre Zelda-Orchester-Soundtrack.
Allerdings, den, den gibt's anscheinend nicht mehr.
Ah, beste, beste, beste, beste Sache ist immer noch der hier.
Was?
Alter, Nintendo, ja.
Das ist immer noch beste Nintendo-Sound ever.
Ja, genau.
Genau.
Gut, reicht jetzt.
Genug, Gabi.
Ah, genug, Gabi.
Ähm, sagen wir, Clocks HD.
Ayaya, ist am Start, zwei Monate, dankeschön.
Nice.
Subscriber.
Da sind paar Comments stehen geblieben.
Vermisse mega die Black Ops 1-Zeit, Kartenwiese, ah, den hatten wir schon.
Übrigens wisst ihr, woran man merkt, dass Black Ops 1 eine andere Zeit war?
Bei WMD.
WMD hat zu Black Ops 1 Zeit.
Und da hat man in der Zeit noch keinen Mensch an weiblich-männlich-divers gedacht.
Sondern es haben alle an Weapons of Mass Destruction gedacht.
Mittlerweile ist was anders.
Wo wir wieder beim Thema sind.
Wobei, ich wollte mich da gar nicht drüber aufregen.
Ich hab heute Morgen News gelesen, dass eine PHP-Konferenz abgesagt wurde,
weil nicht genügend weibliche Sprecher am Start waren.
What the fuck?
Als geht's bei einer IT-Konferenz irgendwie,
das geht ja nicht nur um wer die Vorträge hält,
sondern was der Internet sagt.
sondern was der Inhalt der Vorträge ist.
Aber im Jahr 2019 ist alles nicht mehr so normal im Kopf,
habe ich das Gefühl, was das anbelangt.
Ich bin ja wirklich schon immer...
Ich meine, ich habe Videos gemacht mit Mädels, die Sachen spielen auf YouTube,
bevor diese ganze Geschichte überhaupt im Trend war.
Also ich bin jemand, der prinzipiell sehr davon überzeugt ist,
dass alle Leute das machen sollen oder dass man ihnen die Möglichkeit geben sollte,
das zu machen, was sie sich wünschen zu tun.
Allerdings, man kann es auch nicht erzwingen.
Wenn jemand nicht will, dann hat es keinen Sinn zu sagen, du musst.
Das wäre ja wieder genau das Gegenteil davon.
Du sollst wirklich jedem das ermöglichen, im Rahmen natürlich,
es können nicht alle Astronaut werden, das zu tun, was er machen soll.
Aber du kannst nicht erzwingen, dass auf einer IT-Konferenz,
wo sich eine Frau von 250 Leuten beworben hat, die Hälfte Frauen sind.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Das ergibt doch überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Ich bin dafür, wenn sich da Frauen bewerben,
dann sollte man selbstverständlich auch Frauen einladen, wenn der Talk gut ist.
Aber wenn sich keine Frauen bewerben, wo sollen die denn herkommen?
Egal, das Thema, da habe ich keinen Bock jetzt drauf.
Da habe ich keinen Bock.
Da habe ich keinen Nerv drauf. Das Thema geht mir voll auf den Sack.
Zumal kein Mensch mehr irgendwie halbwegs normal im Kopf ist,
über ob die Sachen diskutieren kann, sondern entweder bist du da übelst zu Spast,
weil sie sagen, du bist dagegen, du bist hier irgendwie Rassist, Nazi, sonst was,
bloß weil du halt nicht zu allem Ja und Amen sagst.
Oder aber du musst übelst auf divers machen.
Was dazwischen ist heute irgendwie kein Platz mehr.
Und ihr wisst, dass ich bei allen Sachen eigentlich,
oder ich bin bei den meisten,
ich bin ganz selten wirklich extrem für was oder extrem gegen was.
Aber da ist heute kein Platz mehr.
Du bist heute entweder auf der einen Seite oder auf der anderen Seite.
Die Seite in der Mitte, das in der Mitte juckt keinen Mensch mehr heute.
Äh, Nacho Libre, die haben ja nicht deswegen abgesagt.
Du musst dir das mal durchlesen.
Die haben abgesagt, die Konferenz wurde abgesagt,
weil zwei männliche Speaker sich übertrieben empört haben,
dass es keine weiblichen Speaker gibt und deswegen ihre Teilnahme abgesagt haben.
Und das waren halt zwei, zwei, drei, also wie nennt man das?
Headline, Headline Speaker, also weswegen die Leute quasi Konferenz Tickets gekauft haben.
Und nachdem die abgesagt haben, hat der Veranstalter gesagt,
okay, hat finanziell keinen Sinn mehr, kauf keiner Tickets.
Ich meine, wenn du deine drei größten Speaker, die zwei Talks haben,
an irgendwie einem Wochenende verlierst,
das, wofür die Leute hingehen,
dann kann ich nachvollziehen, dass man das absagt.
Es ist, es ist, dieses Thema finde ich so unglaublich bescheuert,
vor allem, wie beknackt darüber diskutiert wird.
Man kann ja nicht mehr normal, ups, man kann ja auch gar nicht normal darüber diskutieren.
Entweder bist du dafür, oder du bist dagegen.
So irgendwie, so Krauzone gibt es nicht.
Wobei, die Welt ist halt einfach Krauzone.
Die echte Welt ist Krauzone.
Es gibt es nicht.
Es gibt selten 100% und 0%.
Es gibt öfters 99 und 1%.
Aber 100% und 0% gibt es so gut wie bei nix.
Oder, oder, oder wie es da Sbarro sagt, es ist halt nicht schwarz und weiß.
Fast nix.
Deswegen finde ich die Diskussion, wie darüber diskutiert wird, total beknackt.
Aber wir gucken jetzt weiter, Comments.
Der Max Sox ist gefollowed.
Der Name, den Namen finde ich sehr ansprechend.
Achso, Prime.
2996.
Oh, das ist jetzt aber schon next level hier, oder?
Dass Prime nicht mit Prime abonniert!
Was soll ich denn jetzt für einen Sound machen?
Soll ich jetzt...
Machen!?
Oder soll ich nur?
Was soll ich machen?
Das überfordert mein, mein Hirn gerade massiv.
Wir machen einfach beides.
Ja, das würde sich auch beknackt haben, oder?
Okay, ist gut jetzt.
Damals inspiriert von dir.
Man sieht das sofort am Namen.
Damage.
Oder vielleicht auch
Oder wenn es französisch ist,
Damage.
Wahrscheinlich aber eher Damage.
Abonniert Twitch Prime.
Dankeschön. Nice.
100 Bits. Dankeschön.
Eine Million Bits.
Kann ich auch Poker spielen.
Warum sind die...
Achso, weil ich so klein gemacht habe.
Es war nur der Name
frei 2. Abonniert Twitch Prime.
Pok. Nice.
Und der
ROX ist auch am Start.
Der ROX ist 2 Monate am Start.
Dafür gibt es 360 No Scope.
Dankeschön.
Für die ganzen Subs.
Heute geht es ab.
Es lohnt sich richtig den Kram auf
YouTube anzukündigen.
Das ist huge, huge Sellout Potential.
Habe ich euch eigentlich schon erklärt,
wie toll es ist, wenn man Twitch Prime hat.
Was man da machen kann mit.
Dass der Sellout dich krass überzeugt.
War klar.
Sellout zieht immer.
Max, danke, dass du meine Kindheit, Jugend so begleitet hast.
Ich freue mich jedes Mal, wenn du ein Video hochlädst.
Bitte bleib uns noch etwas auf YouTube und Twitch erhalten.
Das ist nett.
Ich hoffe, du bleibst uns auch noch erhalten.
Sowohl auf YouTube als auch auf Twitch.
Ich muss übrigens mal was sagen.
Erzähl mal.
Das ist jetzt ganz, ganz ohne zu schleimen.
So nach dem Motto, ich habe die besten Subscriber.
Prime Like, Subscribe, bla.
Und Twitch Prime und Donate und Patreon.
Ganz unabhängig davon.
Ich muss echt sagen,
ich weiß, dass mittlerweile
viel mehr zu schätzen,
wie viele Leute
sich freiwillig
und gerne meine geistlichen Ergüsse
auf YouTube angucken oder auch auf Twitch,
wie viele Leute sich freiwillig
auf YouTube angucken.
Früher konnte ich das gar nicht so richtig einschätzen.
Da habe ich gedacht, na gut,
Leute gucken halt gerne Call of Duty.
Mittlerweile habe ich kapiert,
dass die Leute schon
auch gerne Call of Duty
und gerne Battlefield
oder irgendwelche anderen Games gucken.
Aber dass die Leute
tatsächlich hauptsächlich gerne
wegen mir sich den Kram angucken.
Was ja für mich
prinzipiell komplett
so, ne?
das habe ich früher gar nicht so kapiert
äh, hab mir gerade das neue
Linus Tech Tips Videos angesehen
und haben gesagt
dass Netflix VPN anbietet, aber das macht Netflix
schon lange
mit dem Max, der seit jeher eine genderfreundliche
Begrüßung hat, was genderfeindliche
warum
da müsste ich sagen, hallo Jungs und Mädels
hier ist der Max
da müsste ich sagen, hallo
Jungs und Mädels
und
und jetzt müsste ich
erstmal 45 Sachen aufzählen
dass sich jeder angesprochen fühlt oder wie
hallo
MWD
ne ne, ich bleib bei meiner Begrüßung
das Schlimme ist, dass
sowas heute von vielen quasi
schon wieder fast als
halb Nazi gedeutet wird, ja
einfach eine Begrüßung, die ich seit
10 Jahren hab, nach einer halben Stunde
Resub, Joke Gaming, Dankeschön
Twitch App, Twitch App auf Mobile ist grausam
aber sie ist besser geworden
Hazelwood PG, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön, nice
und falsch
Samus Climber, nice
Panzai, zwei Monate, Dankeschön, nice
Samus Climber, Hi Apos
die geht's aber ab
Moin Panzai
und faktisch gibt es eben nur
das Thema, da gehe ich jetzt nicht im Stream drauf ein
und faktisch gibt es eben nur das Thema, da gehe ich jetzt nicht im Stream drauf ein
es gab allerdings schon wenige Übungen
was gar nichts zu
Theresa 또 also
texts
dieser man Particularly
Y기도
Jurich
da sein nichts zu
jakasus dankansel
er erkennt zu flotten er auf Endwo fl illegal
Flutter geht ein richtig richtige richtung
als Cross, Prom präm shortest
Bits wir haben Cerro ist man noch gar nicht aufgefallen
flight oft waren oft mainz
uw likes
ich Liebe frames
Was ist das für ein ekliges Emote?
Killer Tomate.
Äh, Snakery, Twitch Prime, danke.
Ups.
Face reveal bei 1000 Subs.
Hmm.
Also ich hatte ja gesagt, Face reveal bei 1000, äh, bei einer Million Abos.
Weil das eh nix wird.
1000 Subs ist ein Ziel, das ist...
machbar.
Das ist ganz schön viel für die aktuelle Sache, aber das ist...
Das ist machbar irgendwo noch.
Wohingegen eine Million Abos nicht machbar sind.
Also ich würde sagen, bei 2000 Subs.
Bei 2000 Subs würde ich es machen.
Das ist ja voll in Sellout standen.
Bei 2000 Subs würde ich es machen, aber 2000 Subs schaffen wir in nächster Zeit nicht.
Das Subboard wird angeschmissen.
Ja, Moment, so einfach können wir das natürlich nicht machen.
Nicht einfach nur 2000 Subs.
Sondern es müssen auch 2000 konstante Subs...
sein.
Also weil mit 2000 Subs, hätte ich nämlich endlich...
Wie sag ich das jetzt am besten?
Hätte ich, hätte ich, hätte ich so viel, so viel Sellout gemacht, bis ich 2000 Subs hab,
dass ich das wirklich rentieren würde.
Also sollte ich wirklich mal, ohne Scheiß, sollte ich das irgendwie mal hinkriegen.
2000 Subs zu bekommen und ich bin dann auch aktiv auf YouTube und sonst was.
Äh, und das über...
Und das über, über ne, ne ganze Weile.
Und dann hätte ich erstmal keine Geld-Probleme mehr.
Definitiv hätte ich da manche Sachen weniger Probleme, ja.
Also allgemein ist es...
Aber ich sag's, ich sag's nochmal Leute, ohne Scheiß.
Das ärgert mich auch ein bisschen bei anderen Streams, wenn ich sehe.
Wenn ich mir das angucke, dass ich mir, ich, ich, ich...
Ist jetzt egal wo, aber wenn ich mir Streams angucke, wo halt wirklich verdammt junge Leute zu gucken,
die dann quasi ihr letztes, ihr letztes, ihr letzte Kohle, die sie vielleicht sich irgendwie in den Sommerferien verdient haben,
weil sie beim Nachmachen...
Irgendwie, irgendwie Hackel geschnitten haben.
Wenn die diese Kohle Paypal donaten an, an den großen Streamer.
Da blutet mir irgendwie so immer das Herz bei, ja.
Das finde ich total bescheuert.
Die Leute sollen ihr Geld behalten und das für was Sinnvolles für sich selbst ausgeben.
Das brauchen die Leute nicht so dringend, wie sie selbst.
Also ich mein, guck mal, wenn man sich jetzt irgendwie anguckt, lass es mal, lass es mal in den, in den XQC's sein.
Oder in MontanaBlack oder so.
Die bekommen so viele Spenden, da muss man nicht...
Die müssen so eine letzten 5 Euro spenden, wenn man sie selbst besser gebrauchen könnte.
Ich mein, ich will mich nicht beschweren, wenn mich einer subbt oder so.
Ich find das super, ja.
Ähm, und ich weiß, dass ich halt auch viele Leute hab, die eben nicht 12 sind und ihre letzten 5 Euro spenden.
Taschengeld.
Geht auch lieber die letzten 5 Euro bei mir reinzahmen, weil...
Der letzte Song, das ist doch irgendwie so eine Playlist.
Beautiful, beautiful study music.
Der Donate-Button ist weg, weil...
Geht nicht.
Ähm...
Das ist kaputt.
Ich, ich hatte eine Einblendung für Donations.
Und Tippi-Stream hat es irgendwie kaputt gemacht.
Und deswegen hab ich den Donation-Button entfernt, bis Tippi-Stream wieder funktioniert.
Warum nicht Steamlabs?
Ich bin mir gar nicht...
Steamlabs hab ich ja für den Rest.
Ich bin mir nicht mehr sicher, ich glaub Tippi-Stream hatte keine Gebühren oder hatte weniger Gebühren als Steamlabs.
Ich glaub das war der Grund, das hatte einen Grund, warum ich Tippi-Stream genommen hab damals.
Kennst du die Ubiquiti Network?
Klar.
Die nehmen anscheinend die WLAN-Ausstrahlung für Router und das bis zu 100 Meter, je nach Modell.
Kannst du die auf Amazon machen?
Äh, ich, ich hab, ich hab...
Zwei Ubiquiti, ähm...
Access Points und ein Ubiquiti 10 Gigabit-Switch.
Es kann letztendlich...
Es kann jeder suppen, wen er will, ja?
Ich hab's ja vorhin gesagt, wenn's an mir geht, macht jeder, was er will.
Ich hab aber das Gefühl, dass ich manchmal, vor allem besonders junge Leute...
Ähm...
Verpflichtet fühlen, quasi...
Das wenige Geld, was sie haben...
Äh, zu donaten, dass sie irgendwie dazugehören.
Und das ist eigentlich ein Gefühl, das muss man nicht haben.
Es, man, man muss nicht das Gefühl haben, irgendwie...
Man, man würde, man würde irgendwie jetzt quasi sich hier...
Kostenlos entertainen lassen und...
Würde nichts dafür bezahlen, das ist, das ist plötzlich...
Und man muss, man muss auch nicht donaten, man muss nichts spenden, man muss nicht...
Keine Bits, Bits donaten, auch bei mir nicht.
Äh, nur um das Gefühl zu haben, man, man...
Man möchte irgendwie dazugehören.
Ja, ich...
Find's toll, für jeden, der zuguckt.
Ähm...
Ich freu mich über jeden, der zuguckt.
Natürlich freu ich mich auch, wenn einer abonniert, ja?
Wenn einer was donatet, wenn einer Bits, äh, spendet.
Klar, natürlich.
Keine Frage.
Äh...
Oh wein, 4,90, dankeschön, Twitch Prime.
Das war jetzt negativ Sellout, oder?
Das war jetzt negativ Sellout, grade.
Also...
Ich, ich hab vorher geselloutet mit, ihr sollt mich Amazon Prime subscriben.
Und jetzt hab ich erzählt, äh, wann man nicht subscriben soll.
Also bei der Gelegenheit, wollt ich das Ganze nochmal erwähnen.
Ähm, wenn ihr einen Twitch Prime Account habt...
Und, äh, besser gesagt, wenn ihr einen Amazon Prime Account habt, könnt ihr das Ganze mit Twitch verbinden.
Zu einem Twitch Prime Account.
Und ihr könnt damit kostenlos einen Streamer eurer Wahl mit einem Tier-1-Sub unterstützen.
Ist ne ganz normale Subscription.
Gibt alle Emotes dafür, die der Streamer hat.
Wir haben übrigens auch seit heute, äh, drei neue Emotes.
Kostet euch nix.
Und der Streamer bekommt alle Vorteile davon, die er von einem normalen Sub hatte.
Und ihr natürlich auch, was Emotes und Sub-Badges und sowas angeht.
Also das ist kein schlechter Deal, wenn man eh Amazon Prime hat.
Ups.
Sonst haben wir erstmal noch ne schöne Runde Sellout gemacht.
Ich weiß, viele mochten World War 2 nicht.
Aber für mich war das das perfekte Beispiel für das, was du im Video erzählt hast.
Das Spiel hat bis Dezember eine Menge Spaß gemacht.
Und dann ging es los.
Und es gibt noch neue OP-Waffen.
Ähm.
Okay, wusste ich gar nicht, dass es in World War 2 so schlimm war.
Okay.
Also, wo es richtig schlimm war, ist Black Ops 4.
Mit ihren, mit ihrem Black Market Supply Drops.
Und, ähm.
OP, zwei Sekunden, äh, 0,2 Sekunden Double Kill-Waffen und Gedöns.
Also.
Wir haben hier Simpsons Dude.
Zwei Monate.
Aktuell im zweiten fortlaufenden Monat.
Huge.
Big Brain.
IQ vom Chat steigt weiter heute.
Bei so vielen Subs.
Und wen haben wir noch?
Tectonic.
Twitch Prime.
Tectonic, bist du nicht schon im zweiten Monat?
Mir kommt der Name eh schon wie bekannt vor.
Samus Climber.
Nice.
Kommt der Name?
Aber vielleicht bring ich es durcheinander mit jemand, der ähnlich heißt.
Sind schon über 200 Leute auf dem Discord.
Ja, übrigens Leute, wir haben einen Discord.
Haben auf YouTube damals ganz viele Leute.
Mittlerweile haben wir Discord.
Ausrufezeichen Discord.
Wir haben Channels für Technik-Kram, Programmier-Kram, Heim-Automatisierung und Sebaros privates
Archiv.
Nennen wir es mal so, ne?
Eins vor Drohne quasi, quasi, ja.
Sparta.
Trauma.
Twitch Prime.
Nice, danke.
Samus Climber.
Der Chat-IQ heute, der ist schon so hoch, den kann man gar nicht mal in, kann man gar
nicht mal darstellen in irgendwelchen Emotes.
Äh, Sassmarx finde, der Boss ist back.
Sieben.
Finde mega, dass du momentan so aktiv bist.
Ich hoffe, das bleibt auch so.
Also ich bin motiviert.
Mal gucken, wie lange das hält.
Ich muss, das Wichtigste ist, Leute, ohne Scheiß, da müsst ihr mich unterstützen bei.
Ich weiß nicht genau wie, aber da müsst ihr mich echt unterstützen bei.
Hallo zu Mädels, hier ist der Max.
Die ersten zwei Wochen, ich muss die ersten zwei Wochen durchhalten.
Weil die ersten zwei Wochen dauert es immer, bis, bis YouTube sich wieder eingekriegt hat.
Bis YouTube alle inaktiven Subs aufgeräumt hat.
Ähm, bis YouTube, bis der YouTube-Algorithmus wieder gecheckt hat, dass man aktiv ist.
14 Tage, die ersten 14 Tage ist das Kritische.
Weil die ersten 14 Tage kann ich die besten Videos vom Besten hochladen und ich werde
auf keinen grünen Zweig bei neuen Abos kommen.
Das ist jedes Mal so, wenn du neu anfängst bei YouTube.
Das dauert immer.
Das dauert immer ungefähr 14 Tage.
Bis es konstant nach oben geht.
Also was Abo-Zahlen angeht.
Also ihr müsst mich, ich meine nicht, dass ihr subscriben müsstet.
Weil in irgendeiner Form brauche ich da eure volle Energy, dass ich das 14 Tage durchhalte alles.
Warum kopierst du die ganze Zeit Buchstaben?
Dazu gibt es einen Clip.
Ausrufzeichen 1.
Ich gucke mir den Clip jetzt mal selbst an.
Weil ich habe keine Ahnung mehr, was ich da überhaupt erzählt habe.
Die volle Q-Chat-Energie.
Also was habe ich denn selbst mal erzählt, warum ich immer Buchstaben kopiere?
Ich paste so und dann cutte.
Ups.
Und dann auscutte.
Oder auch, was ich ganz gerne mache, irgendwas rechts anklicken und dann auf Copy und so.
Das ist einfach, einfach Tick von mir.
Richtig.
So hier.
So war es in der Richtung.
Das hat nichts, nichts, nichts zu sagen.
Und ich glaube, das liegt daran.
Weil.
Ich mir das zu Zeiten angewöhnt habe, wo man noch viel ICQ-Text-Nachrichten geschickt hat.
Und ich habe sehr viel ICQ-Text-Nachrichten immer, immer Teile von Copy-Pasted.
Wenn man also Sachen, die sich wiederholt haben und so.
Und da hatte ich immer Schiss, dass ich aus Versehen dem oder der Falschen, wie auch immer.
Dann aus Versehen die falsche Nachricht schicke.
Was weiß ich, wenn ich über einen geflamed habe, wollte ich dem das nicht gerade schicken.
Ich erinnere mich wieder, dass ich das gesagt habe.
Ja, richtig.
Das stimmt auch, was ich gesagt habe.
Deswegen habe ich mir angewöhnt, mein Clipboard irgendwie leer zu machen.
Aber eigentlich komplett demachsinn.
Es ist Schwachsinn.
Richtig, Max.
Eigentlich ist es Schwachsinn.
Aber mach es trotzdem.
Das ist die Erklärung dazu, warum ich immer irgendwelche Sachen kopiere.
Wupplull.
Moment, warum?
Warum habe ich Wupp?
Warum habe ich Wupplull überhaupt nicht in meinem, in meinem Board drinne?
Moment.
Wupplull.
Oh ne.
Ich habe mein eigenes Emote nicht mehr.
Also es ist ja gar nicht so wirklich mein Emote.
Das habe ich mir, das habe ich mir kopiert und Pixel abgeändert.
Ja.
Aber ich habe es nicht mehr.
Wo habe ich es denn hin?
Wupplull.
Wupplull ist weg.
Es gibt doch so eine, warte mal.
Twitch Emotes.
Da gibt es doch so eine Seite, die das alles, die das alles hat.
Ja, gehen wir fort.
Wupplull.
Channel not found.
Fuck.
Und Wuppold ist ja auch nicht drinne.
Old.
Wuppold.
Fuck.
Okay, da habe ich die auf einem anderen Account.
Holy shit.
Ich habe gerade nicht auf dem Stream gehört und war Confused, als zwei Mucks gesprochen
haben.
Ja, kann ich verstehen, wenn man nicht zuguckt.
Ja, so, so sieht übrigens die Oberfläche aus von diesem, von diesem Meme Sound Einplant
Board.
Haben wir auch teilweise im Stream programmiert.
Ist allerdings schon eineinhalb Jahre oder so her.
Warum habe ich meine, ich habe die eine Katze drin.
Warum habe ich die andere Katze nicht auch drin?
Na, was auch immer.
Voll krass, dich auf Twitch zu finden.
Hab dich geschaut mit 13.
Heute bin ich 20.
Genau das Thema hatten wir vor einer halben Stunde.
Das ist unglaublich, wie viele Leute damals irgendwie 12, 13 waren.
Heute 20, 21.
Samolon, das kannst du ja nicht erzählen.
Die gibt es nicht mehr.
Ich hatte so ein bisschen Pech mit meinen letzten zwei Katzen.
Ja, die waren aber schon alle alt.
Die waren schon alle alt.
Chico, Chico ist auch alt.
Aber Chico ist nicht ganz alt.
Aber Chico ist nicht ganz so alt.
Chico ist, Chico ist glaube ich neun.
Neun oder zehn.
Die erste war, die erste war glaube ich, die erste war 14, 15.
Und Barbie war, die hieß wirklich Barbie, die andere, ja.
Die habe ich nicht so genannt.
Das haben sich die Vorbesitzer ausgedacht.
Barbie, ich würde meine Katze normalerweise nie Barbie nennen.
Barbie war auch irgendwie elf, zwölf.
Wann kommt Klo und Aufzug Update?
Also Klo gibt es nichts Neues.
Und Aufzug ist ja weg.
Weil Dach isoliert.
Chico geht es gut.
Chico ist voll zufrieden.
Voll zufrieden mit Katz.
5000 Euro Amazon Shopping.
Kreditkartenprobleme.
Aber warum wohl?
Erst, erst einmal, erst einmal die Rolex, erst einmal die Rolex gekauft, Rolex bestellt.
Letztens im Stream-Ausschnitt gesehen, wo sie sich irgendwie Rolex-Uhren für 55k oder so angeguckt, 75k angeguckt haben.
Man gönnt sich ja sonst nichts.
Es war so eine kleine Rolex nebenbei.
Easy, easy as fuck.
By the way, kommt das Staubsauger-Update-Video.
Ach ja, stimmt, Leute.
Also es ist jetzt 21 Uhr.
Ich habe es euch ja versprochen.
Ich wollte euch ja mal den Staubsauger zeigen für alle, die über YouTube kommen.
Die Leute, die hier aus dem Chat da sind, die kennen das ja schon.
Den habe ich ja schon mal gezeigt.
Ich wollte euch ja das Webinterface, den Webinterface vom Staubsauger zeigen.
Ja.
Das ist das Webinterface vom Staubsauger.
Die, oh, die Map ist kaputt.
Die Map ist kaputt, sonst, warum ist die Map kaputt?
Weiß ich nicht.
Also zumindest ist es dieser Staubsauger hier.
IP League, oh ja.
MonkaS.
Hexor.
Ah, am Start.
Der Sibaro wieder.
Erst wird Fappy Bird gespielt und jetzt ist es der Robocock.
Ja, also das Ding.
Ähm, ist, finde ich, der beste Staubsauger-Roboter, den es zurzeit gibt preis-leistungsmäßig, wenn er im Angebot ist.
Und die Dinger sind recht oft im Angebot für bis zu 300, 320.
Also wenn ihr den irgendwo mal für 320 seht oder für 280 sogar, das ist wahrscheinlich ein anderer.
Also 280 ist ein Megapreis.
280 ist ein Megapreis.
Ähm.
Mal gucken, das ist bestimmt Fake News, dass das.
Ah, haha, siehste.
Sag ich doch, Fake.
Äh, also wenn ihr mit dem für 320 oder so könnt, das ist der beste Staubsauger-Roboter, den ihr euch holen könnt.
Erstens ist die Performance als Staubsauger-Roboter gut.
Der hat, ähm, den extra Teppich, Teppich, ich zeige euch das gleich, Teppichsaugmodus.
Nur mal, dass ihr das Ding gesehen habt.
Also der Staubsauger-Roboter ist super.
Allerdings, das große Problem ist, warum ich ihn nicht empfehlen kann, wenn man technisch nicht so versiert ist,
ist, ähm, der funktioniert halt nur mit der offiziellen App.
Und die offizielle App ist halt mit, mit, mit Cloud, mit Cloud in China.
Also sprich, wer damit, wer damit keine Probleme hat, seine, seine Staubsauger, seinen Grundriss in die Cloud nach China zu übertragen,
für den ist das nicht so ein Problem.
Was für mich ein Problem ist, erstens meinen Grundriss und Daten in die China-Cloud zu übertragen,
mein WLAN-Passwort und alles, ja, ich glaube, es geht los.
Was für mich ein Problem ist, ich finde es bescheuert, dass mein Staubsauger nicht geht,
sollte ich kein Internet haben, oder die China-Cloud nicht erreichbar sein.
Es, es ist komplett hirnrissig, den Staubsauger nicht funktionsfähig zu haben, sollte das Internet weg sein.
Deswegen...
...wird das Ding geflasht.
Deswegen habe ich das Ding geflasht.
Und geflasht ist es der wirklich, ohne Scheiß, der preis-leistungsmäßig unschlagbar beste Staubsauger-Roboter, den ihr euch vorstellen könnt.
Webinterface sieht folgendermaßen aus.
Also hier sieht man eigentlich den Grundriss normalerweise, ich habe es irgendwie kaputt gemacht oder so.
Hier sieht man den Grundriss von meinem Wohnzimmer gerade.
Der hat so einen Laser oben drauf.
Hier.
Da scannt er die Räume.
Und da kann man jetzt, kann man Zonen definieren.
Ah, habe ich zum Beispiel unten Treppe, Wohnzimmer, Flur, Schlafzimmer, Küche, Bad, oben Bad, oben Flur, oben Wohnzimmer, oben Schlafzimmer, Teppich.
Ähm...
Und da kann man hier im...
Man kann ihn übrigens manuell kontrollen.
Man kann ihn, glaube ich, sogar mittlerweile mit Controller kontrollen.
Du könntest ein Video machen, wie man den flasht.
Habe ich auf dem Channel als Highlight hochgeladen, musst du mal gucken.
Letzte Highlight-Video ist der Stream, wo ich das geflasht habe.
Ähm...
Nennt sich LiDAR-Sensor.
Ne, LiDAR-Sensor ist, ist ähm...
Kein Laser, oder?
Ist LiDAR-Sensor nicht die Radar-Geschichte gewesen?
Das ist zumindest, der hat zumindest mit Laser oben drauf.
Ähm...
Und ist halt super einfach zu bedienen.
Also auch die übelsten Noobs können das bedienen.
Das Ding hat, glaube ich, eine Zeit von bis zu 3 Stunden, wo es fährt.
Hat einen relativ hohen...
Relativ hohen...
Relativ großen Tank.
Dazu kommt, dass man theoretisch auch Boden wischen kann.
Benutze ich aber nicht, finde ich.
Finde ich un...
Un...
Unsinnig.
Ähm...
Und ist halt wirklich praktisch.
Du kannst sagen...
Achso, wenn du auf Feind drückst und man das deutsche Sprachpaket installiert hat, sagt
er...
Hallo!
Hier bin ich!
In so total beknackter, ähm...
Sprache.
Dann müsst ihr da mal das Weep-Sound-Paket dafür entwerfen.
Er macht dann Ayaya, wenn du ihn suchst.
Ah, du kannst hier einstellen, ähm...
Die...
Was er machen soll.
Also wie brutal er zu Werke geht.
Ähm...
Du kannst einstellen...
Okay.
Oh, hab ich ihn jetzt angeschaltet gerade?
Okay, was auch immer.
Ähm...
Man kann ihn quasi losschicken, wo er hinfahren soll.
Man fährt dann hin, macht's sauber und fährt selbstständig zum Dock wieder zurück.
Das ist halt wirklich cool.
So.
Ähm...
Und in den Settings, was auch noch nice ist...
Der hat nen...
Achso, man kann auch virtuelle Walls aufstellen, dass der...
Dass der, ähm...
In manche Bereiche nicht hinfährt.
Also...
Ähm...
einstellen, wie er hochdreht.
Und seitdem
ist mega nice im Wohnzimmer drüben.
Die Katz rollt sich halt gerne
auf dem Teppich rum und alles.
Ähm...
Blockwatcher, das haben wir uns schon mal
überlegt. Ob wir nicht einen
Stream machen, so aus Spaß.
Twitch Place Cleaning Apartment.
Was, wenn er durch Katzenkacke
fährt? Verschmiert er es dann in der Wohnung?
Ja, wenn es ein Riesenhaufen ist,
ja. Ach da.
Ja. Die Katze hat aber noch nirgends
wohin gekackt. Außerdem
fährt er nicht einfach
random. Das kann man übrigens auch machen. Man kann einstellen,
dass der
zu bestimmten Zeiten fährt und sowas.
Ich lasse den aber immer gezielt in den Zimmer
fahren, ja. Also wenn ich sage,
okay, jetzt ist Wohnzimmer, Wohnzimmer mit Teppich
dran.
Wasche die Tür auf, gucke einmal rein und lasse ihn dann da hinfahren.
Ja, und das Coole daran ist,
seitdem ich hier im Wohnzimmer, also hier in der Mitte
ist ein Teppich,
ähm, seitdem ich den habe und das Ding
ordentlich hochdreht, im Vergleich zu meinem
anderen, den ich habe,
ähm, ist, sind da
total wenig Katzenhaare und alles
ist sehr sauber auf dem Teppich.
Und ich bin ja jemand,
ich kann Hausarbeit überhaupt
nicht ab.
Deswegen sauge ich jetzt bloß noch alle, alle
Schaltjahre mal, seitdem ich die ganzen Staubsauger
Roboter am Start habe.
Also kann ich, kann ich
nur empfehlen, das Ding.
Was sagt KatzFPS zu dem Roboter?
Die guckt immer ein bisschen kritisch, aber die hat da,
Chico hat da wenig Probleme mit dem Staubsauger.
Ja, und was
an dem, was an dem Staubsauger-Roboter
auch nice ist, dadurch,
dass er diesen Scanner oben hat, wo er den Raum
abtastet, fährt er halt
auch gezielt. Der fährt einfach zickzack,
nicht zickzack, der fährt einfach Linien in den Raum ab
und ist ziemlich schnell mit dem Zimmer fertig.
Kann man das Flaschen und Routen
rückgängig machen?
Ja, kann man, glaube ich.
Kann man, kann man ziemlich sicher.
Will ich aber nicht.
At all,
fragt der Chico,
die helfen können.
Ich kenne mich im Serverbereich nicht aus.
Was für Hardware ist empfehlenswert,
wenn man lediglich einen File
und einen Plex-Media-Server betreiben möchte?
File-Server ist, könnte ich dir
einfach beantworten, Plex-Server
kommt darauf an, ob du transcoden willst oder nicht
und für wie viele User gleichzeitig.
Ja, File-Server ist natürlich
auch ein bisschen davon abhängig, wie viele User gleichzeitig,
allerdings bei Gigabit-Ethernet
ist das, was ja Standard ist,
ist halt voll, wenn Gigabit
voll ist.
Ja, File-Server ist easy,
da brauchst du nichts Großartiges für,
es sei denn, du möchtest
irgendwie
ZFS, De-Duplication,
Encryption mit
Kompression und Geduld, aber willst du wahrscheinlich nicht.
Das ist schwierig,
aber Plex ist schwer zu beantworten.
Knärbär,
Sub ist in 8 Tagen zu Ende.
Würde ich sagen, 2. Monat.
The Legion, 2 Monate, huge,
danke schön, Staubsauger-Hype, Rare Parrot,
dann kriegst du's,
dann kriegst du für deinen Subscriber-E-Mode, den hier.
Sogar den hier.
Huge.
Ups.
Manchmal verdrück ich mich irgendwie.
You've got to be...
Okay, ähm...
Oh, wir haben schon 21 oder 15.
Es kann übrigens sein, dass ich morgen schon
ein bisschen früher anfangen kann zu streamen,
weil ich hab morgen Home-Office
und geh zum Doktor, weil mir schon
seit 1,5 Wochen der Hals übelst weh tut.
Ist irgendwie ganz merkwürdig, Halsweh.
Also, ich hab morgen Homeoffice und geh zum Doktor, weil mir schon seit 1,5 Wochen der Hals übelst weh tut.
Also, nicht da, wo man normalerweise Halsweh hat, wenn man...
Und hat auch damit nichts zu tun,
ja, nur mal so, um irgendwelchen Sachen wieder vorzubeugen.
Ähm...
Keine Ahnung.
Es kann durchaus sein, dass der mich morgen krank schreibt
und sagt, hier, ausruhen.
Dann kann ich morgen ein bisschen früher streamen schon.
Und wenn nicht, mach ich Homeoffice und bin früher wieder daheim.
Also, instant daheim, wenn ich fertig bin.
Max, mach bitte nie wieder den blinkenden Vogel am Ende vom Witt.
Hab davon einen halbnen epileptischen Anfall bekommen.
Ja, ganz bestimmt.
Das ist doch G-Bait.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass man davon einen Anfall kriegt.
Oder?
Ich mein, ich will jetzt keinem zu nahe treten, irgendwie.
Also, ich kenn mich damit nicht aus.
Also, solltest du das wirklich ernst meinen?
Ja, der Boss ist back.
War nachts mit Handy im Zimmer auf jeden Fall hart, okay.
Und der geht, oder was?
Also, jetzt ist es nicht wild, oder wie?
Aber, was ist mit dem hier?
Was ist mit dem grünen Papagei?
Ich find ihn grad nicht, ehrlich gesagt.
Hier, der da, was mit dem?
War nur auf Choke-Basis, dachte ich mir.
Aber man weiß ja nie, also ich kenn mich mit sowas nicht aus.
Ich mein, dass irgendwelche Leute Anfälle kriegen, will ich ja wirklich nicht.
G-Baited, ich sag doch G-Bait.
Ja, Matt, das kann ich verstehen, dass der Vogel anstrengend ist.
Mentos BFH.
Seh ich das richtig?
Cassandra BFH stands for Battlefield Hardline...
Aber danke für den Twitch Prime Sub!
Battlefield Heroes, ja das könnte natürlich auch sein!
Ja, lieber Battlefield Heroes als Battlefield Hardliner!
Wobei, nee, Moment, ich bring das durch!
Hieros' Comic-Look 3D-Play?
Al so' extrem Scheiße war Hardline gar nicht!
Buradaкон, okay...
Speedrun-Video, ja ich brauche erst mal einen mit dem ich ein Speedrun-Video machen kann.
ビ moments kurz ausschalten...
Ja, es kann durchaus sein, dass Battlefield Hardline geschadet hat.
Ja, könnte sein.
Also Battlefield 4 kannst du auf jeden Fall noch spielen.
Battlefield 4 hat ziemlich viele Spieler.
Schau mal.
Battlefield 4 hat auf dem PC-Peak, sagen wir mal, 10.000.
Jetzt pass mal auf.
Battlefield 4 hat fast ähnlich viele wie Battlefield 1.
Und über alle Plattformen zusammen hat Battlefield 4, würde ich sagen, fast mehr.
Leider, Leute, leider gibt es keine Battlefield 4.
Da gehen wir nicht drauf.
Da gehen wir nicht drauf auf diese Seite.
Soll ich auch nochmal einen Tick von mir zeigen?
Jedes Mal, wenn ich auf so eine G-Bait-Seite gekommen bin,
mache ich immer erst den Prozess-Explorer auf
und gucke, ob ich mir nicht irgendeinen Virus eingefangen habe.
Das ist auch so ein Tick, den ich habe.
Immer wenn ich auf so eine G-Bait-Seite bin,
immer wenn ich auf so eine G-Bait-Seite unter Windows gelandet bin,
man weiß ja nie, weil es Windows ist.
Ich bin nicht auf der Seite gelandet, es kann nichts passiert sein.
Mache ich immer Prozess-Explorer auf und gucke,
ob irgendwelche verdächtigen Aktivitäten auf dem Rechner laufen.
Und aktuell sehe ich keine verdächtigen Aktivitäten aus,
außer irgendwelche Microsoft-Shit, der im Hintergrund läuft.
Ach ja, und was auch übelst lächerlich ist,
dass diese komische Corsar-Software fürs Nichtstun permanent CPU-Last verbraucht.
Jubidai!
Verschenkt ein Stück!
Stufe 1 Abo an die Community!
Und zwar das erste Geschenk von...
...auf diesem Kanal, und zwar an...
...Wambo333!
Dankeschön, Subscriber!
Bezüglich Windows-Hintergrund-Prozesse...
Nee, ich schraube da nichts dran rum.
Es ist ja nicht so, als würde es mein Rechner irgendwie großartig langsamer machen.
Ich weiß, dass der...
...dass der Prozess-Explorer Virus total sammeln kann.
Was hältst du denn von Cyberpunk?
Das ist eine interessante Frage, das hatten wir schon ein paar Mal.
Äh, freust du dich schon auf den nächsten Teil?
Was?
Den nächsten Teil?
Kommt doch jetzt der erste Teil des Cyberpunk raus.
Moment, what?
Gibt es schon Cyberpunk 2078?
Ich wäre ja eigentlich eher gewesen für Cyberpunk 2096.
Äh, 2069.
Hast du COD eigentlich schon vorbestellt?
Nein.
Kein COD vorbestellt.
Stell nichts mehr vor.
Die Ausnahme habe ich vorhin am Anfang erzählt.
Auf YouTube schreibt gerade einer, er hat den Stream verpasst.
Er kann nicht geguckt haben, weil der Stream ist noch on.
Das letzte Metro-Gespiel?
Nee, noch nicht.
Ich bin aber...
Ich habe es schon oft gesagt, ich bin kein Fan von Open-World-Spielen.
Cyberpunk ist so eine Sache.
Witcher hat es geschafft, durch eine ordentliche rote Linie und eine gute Hauptquelle...
... hat dafür gesorgt, dass man eben auch in der Open-World einen Faden hat, ja, einen Weg irgendwie.
Aber reine Open-World-Sandbox-Spiele sind halt echt nicht mein Fall.
Ähm, deswegen mag ich auch GTA Online und so Zeug überhaupt nicht.
Und ich glaube, dass CD Projekt das eigentlich kann.
Dazu kommt noch bei Cyberpunk, dass ich das Setting an sich nicht mag.
Es sind schon zwei Sachen, die mir an dem Spiel nicht gefallen.
Sowohl das Setting ist nicht wirklich meins.
Also quasi dieser Zukunfts... dieser düstere Zukunftsstelz.
Und, ähm, dass ich halt mit Open-World auch nicht so... nicht allzu viel anfangen kann.
Deswegen bin ich jetzt niemand, der super gehypt ist auf Cyberpunk.
Aber ich bin gespannt, was rauskommt.
Und ich gehe davon aus, dass ich... GTA 5 mag ich auch nicht.
GTA mag ich auch nicht.
Hast du die Stalker-Reihe gespielt? Ja.
Ja.
Dann wird demnächst etwas Neues kommen?
Idespin...
Hast du Geburtstag?
Wenn ja, dann kratze.
Five hat Wine...
Dann kommt die neue Gartentour.
Es wird Zeit für ein...
Im Grashalm Revealed.
Es hat sich nichts getan im Garten.
Lass mal alle zusammen ein eigenes Soundpac...
Soundpac...
Soundpack...
Für den Staubsauger-Roboter erstellen.
Das war eine lustige Idee, ja.
Ne.
WoW fange ich nicht an.
Wenn ich...
Wenn ich WoW anfange,
würde, dann würde ich
keine Videos mehr machen, keinen Stream mehr machen und nix.
Dann würde ich
nix mehr machen.
Ist dein Chrome-Browser auch ein bisschen langsamer mit Dark
oder bild ich mir das nicht, dass ich es gemerkt hätte?
Weepshit.
Ja, das ist nur, um
meine Mods zu erfreuen.
Und die ganzen restlichen Weeps hier.
Da haben wir ja jede Menge.
Die haben mich auch dazu überredet, so viele Weep-Emotes
bei BetterDwitchTV einzufügen.
Oder meinst du,
ich wäre selbst auf die Idee gekommen, irgendwelche
Ableck-Emotes einzubauen?
Aber ich will ja,
dass, ja, wir sind ja hier, wie sagt man so,
wir sind ja inclusive, ja.
Also wenn Weeps Weeps-Emote
wollen, dann kriegen Weeps Weeps-Emote.
Ich hab da kein Problem für.
Solange es subscribed wird, ist das,
solange das Setout läuft,
ist mir das egal. Da kriegt jeder seine Emotes,
die er haben will.
Rigaton100,
Twitch Prime, dankeschön, nice.
Als was arbeitest du eigentlich?
Ausrufezeichen Beruf.
Zockst du eigentlich noch zwischendurch mit dem Friseur?
Äh, der Friseur spielt hauptsächlich
Black Desert und Black Desert hat mich,
der spielt sogar mittlerweile mit meinem Account.
Wahrscheinlich hab ich schon das übertriebenste
OP-Gear mittlerweile wieder.
Ähm, aber BDO ist nix, was mich
jetzt so bei der Laune gehalten hat.
Liest du Bücher?
Nö.
Ich erhöre Bücher manchmal.
Ah, ich lese, ich lese.
Das einzige, was ich an Büchern lese, sind,
sind, äh,
Technik-Geschichten, ja.
Irgendwelche Programmier-Programmiersachen oder so.
Äh, der Fabian
spielt immer noch BDO, klar.
Was denkst du von
Kotlin als Einstieg
zur App-Programmierung?
Äh, ich, zu Java-Sachen darfst du mich
nix fragen. Ich hab nur gehört
von ein paar Java-Entwicklern bei uns auf der Arbeit,
dass sie froh wäre, mit Kotlin
arbeiten zu können, als mit, äh,
als wenn sie das benutzen könnten,
anstatt ihr normales Java-Zeug.
Wie findest du eigentlich
Spontana Black?
Guckt das eigentlich zu wenig, dass ich da jetzt irgendwie
ne großartige
Meinung mir bilden könnte?
Keine Ahnung.
Ist nicht mein Content, ja.
Ich kann auch zu allen, ich kann auch zu den
ganzen anderen Leuten auf YouTube mittlerweile wenig sagen.
Ich hab zum Beispiel keine Ahnung, was,
was macht der Muscle so zum Beispiel?
Was macht der, was macht der,
das Skorpion oder hier der Dings hier,
wie heißt, wie ist der andere?
Äh,
sein Kumpel da.
Ich hab's, ich hab's schon, ich weiß schon gar nicht,
ähm,
ich weiß gar nicht, ich weiß nicht,
was die alle machen. Ich guck das,
ich guck das nicht mehr. Ich hab das voll aus den Augen
verloren. Das liegt aber einfach daran,
dass es mein, dass es, dass es nicht,
dass es kein Content für mich ist in dem Sinn,
ja. Die machen kein Content für Leute,
die 35 sind.
Oder Inscope, Inscope guck ich
auch nicht. Ich halte, ich halte den Niko
für den, für den Original
Lifestyle Channel,
auf YouTube, den wir in Deutschland haben.
Der war quasi,
so, so, so die,
die Inspiration für viele, ja.
Und der Niko an sich ist auch ein wirklich,
ähm, zumindest früher, ja, sehr netter, äh,
äh, Kerl gewesen. Ähm,
wie es jetzt ist, weiß ich nicht.
Leute ändern sich ja mit der Zeit auch.
Ähm, aber verfolge ich auch, verfolge ich alles nicht.
Kann dazu, ehrlich gesagt, nichts sagen.
Niska Barca hat ne 200k Nachzahlung,
als Finanzamt offen.
Wenn einer ne 200k Nachzahlung als Finanzamt
offen hat, kann man davon ausgehen, dass er an sich
nicht gerade am Hungertuch nagt, weil
irgendwo müssen die 200k ja herkommen,
die man nachzahlen muss.
Er lebt, ihr Lord trägt es eigentlich noch.
Kein Schimmer.
Habe ich auch nie wirklich Kontakt, großartig.
Kennst du gute Videos oder Beiträge,
wo erklärt wird, wie man was
für den Raspberry Pi programmiert?
Du programmierst ja nicht wirklich was für den Raspberry Pi,
sondern du, du nimmst
ne Programmiersprache und programmierst
da drin was und kannst,
was auf dem Raspberry Pi laufen lassen.
Es sei denn, du meinst, wie du irgendwelche Pins
und sowas vom Raspberry Pi ansteuerst.
Niko streamt auch bei Twitch.
Ja, hab ich gesehen, hab ich gesehen.
Wird wieder Zeit, in die Szene einzusteigen.
Es gibt die Szene doch gar nicht mehr.
Guck mal, die machen jetzt alle Fitnessvideos
oder Lifestyle-Gedöns
oder, oder
Bombenpranks oder was, was,
keine Ahnung, das,
das ist bestimmt kein Content, wo ich
irgendwie einsteigen könnte,
oder noch einsteigen möchte.
Das wird zu blöd.
Das ist, wie gesagt, mit 35
bin ich auch nicht derjenige,
wo irgendjemand das krasse
ähm, äh,
Lifestyle-Video sehen will.
Was soll ich da machen?
Frankfurt City, Lifestyle,
Goethestraße, Louis Vitor Store,
zahl die Kollektion bar,
fick auf Sponsor.
Soll ich machen.
Collaboration mit Haftbefehl im Frankfurter Ghetto.
Was für ein Auto fährst du?
Hauptsächlich keins.
Iska wurde von seiner Schwester abgezogen.
Ach, ich würd nicht alles glauben,
was auf YouTube so erzählt wird.
Da ist so viel Bullshit im Umlauf.
Marcel macht Werbung für Pornosäulen.
Naja, soll er doch.
Manch einer spielt Flappy, Fappy Bird
und manch einer macht Werbung für Pornosäulen.
Nie Steuern überwiesen.
Naja, gut.
Also, wer so viel verdient und nie Steuern überweist,
der ist
das Gegenteil von
so.
Also, das erste, was ich gemacht hab,
als ich angefangen hab mit YouTube
ein bisschen Kohle zu verdienen,
den Kram angemeldet und Steuern bezahlt.
Weil ich keinen Bock auf so
Kack habe, dass sowas passiert.
Ne, Montana Black ist nicht 35, oder?
Ich glaub, der ist doch erst 30.
Dass es die 10 nicht mehr gibt,
liegt auch daran, dass alle Cods scheiße sind.
Die 10 an sich, es gibt schon noch relativ viele Leute,
die Call of Duty
Content machen. Letztens hab ich zum Beispiel was,
Haptic Rush, oder so,
gibt's noch. Gibt's noch.
Fantu macht noch Call of Duty Videos.
Es gibt schon noch ein paar. Es ist ja nicht, dass es
komplett weg wär.
Das hat er selbst erzählt. Ja, selbst wenn jemand was
als müsste man
was drauf geben, nur weil einer auf YouTube
irgendwas erzählt.
Boah, wie viel Blödsinn auf YouTube erzählt wird.
Auch wenn er das selbst erzählt, ist es fragwürdig,
ob ich das alles so glauben würde.
KSFreak und
CrappyWhatElse
sind auch beide insolvent. Wer war das
nochmal? Ach!
Hat sich der Friseur
nicht mal auf der Gamescom mit dem KSFreak
in den Haaren vor, vor irgendwie 8 Jahren
oder so. Das einzige, wo ich mich da irgendwie noch dran
erinnern kann.
Wie lange fährst du mit der Bahn
zur Arbeit?
Meinst du von Tür zu Tür?
Oder Fahrzeitbahn?
Schau dir doch mal das neue Inscope
Video an. Ne, ich weiß, was der Nico
für Videos macht.
Ich weiß aber auch, dass
das nicht Content für mich ist.
Ja, dass das nicht Content ist, der mich
anspricht. Du hältst aber echt gut
an der 240 sogar. Nice.
Heute ist viel. Finde ich übrigens cool,
wie viele Leute von Youtube da sind.
Was sagst du dazu, dass PewDiePie
die 100 Millionen geknackt hat?
Ich finde es schade, dass T-Series
ihn überholt hat.
Was interessieren mich Bollywood Musikvideos?
PewDiePie ist, ganz ehrlich,
ich fand den Typ früher
übelst kacke.
Ich hätte mir den Kram nie anguckt.
Aber ich habe mir vor einer Weile mal
ein paar Videos von ihm angeguckt.
Also vor einer Weile. Vor 3 Jahren.
Oder so. Der ist gar nicht
blöd. Der ist gar nicht blöd.
Und so dämlich
manche Videos auf den ersten Blick
wirken, ist
da schon eine gewisse, also du merkst, dass der Typ
nicht blöd ist.
Und viele Sachen sind halt auch wirklich lustig.
Ohne, dass er lacht dabei.
Also das ist jemand, den
kann ich mir tatsächlich angucken.
Emotes. Ja, gibt es jetzt Emotes.
Oh, ich habe einen Sub verpasst.
Meister Makrele. Habe ich noch mehr verpasst?
Meister Makrele ist am Start.
Und wen haben wir noch?
Nee, Rigaton100
hatten wir schon. Meister Makrele, dankeschön.
Twitch Prime.
Für jede Minute, wo ich vergessen habe,
es vorzulesen.
Wobei, nicht so lange warst du dann auch wieder nicht her.
Zieh einfach weiter dein Ding durch.
Egal, was die anderen machen.
Und Gaming wird ja auch ganz gut bezahlt, CPM-mäßig.
Das ist mir wurscht.
Also, die AdSense-Verdienste
sind immer ziemlich egal.
Das, womit Kohle verdient wird, sind
die zusätzlichen Deals.
Ich muss jetzt erstmal, und das habe ich ja
vorhin auch schon gesagt, ihr müsst mir da wirklich
ein bisschen helfen,
dass ich die Motivation behalte.
Weil die ersten 14 Tage, wenn man wieder neu
auf YouTube anfängt, das sind die schwierigsten.
Sowohl, also
YouTube-Algorithmus-technisch,
Subscriber-mäßig, weil die erstmal aufgeräumt wird
und halt das Algorithmus-mäßig
wieder in Schwung kommt. Und vor allem,
Innovations-mäßig.
Da brauche ich hier Energy.
Saipai kann ich nichts zu sagen.
Ich habe ihn mal
5 Sekunden auf der Gamescom getroffen.
Ich kann zu der Person nichts sagen.
Aber wenn jemand
so viele Leute
anspricht, muss ja
zumindest der Content
Gaming-technisch ganz gut sein.
Weil das ist themenbezogener Call-of-Duty-Kram.
Unabhängig davon,
ob man ihn selbst toll findet oder nicht.
Aber scheint die Gaming-Komponente schon mal nicht verkehrt zu sein.
Für die Emotes sagt man doch alles.
Nice Emote. Was sagt ihr eigentlich zu den
neuen Emotes? Also außer
das einzige Emote, was ich
selbst gemacht habe, ist WubCup.
WubS ist von jemand auf dem Discord.
WubLul
habe ich von
FFZ geklaut und leicht abgeändert.
Und WubOld auch.
Anzeige ist raus direkt.
Und dazu
Sebarro, du hast Recht. Alter, was ist
mit dem Chat los?
Der Chat ist richtig nice.
Wir mussten heute noch nicht einen bannen
oder irgendwie time-outen
oder sonst was.
PewDiePie ist auch verheiratet, ich weiß.
Wen ich überhaupt nicht mag,
übrigens danke für die ganzen Subs, ich bin
im Chat noch nicht so weit, ich guck gleich.
Wen ich oder was
ich überhaupt nicht mag, sind
so diese
Wie soll ich das am besten
nennen? So diese
Let's Player Persönlichkeiten,
die
alles mögen.
Ich kann das schwierig beschreiben.
Nicht PewDiePie, der mag nicht alles.
So die Let's Play Typen,
die
schwierig zu beschreiben.
Haben wir in Deutschland auch ein paar.
Aber es gibt
so Let's Play
Persönlichkeiten, das ist für mich
der Inbegriff von
Wie könnte man dazu sagen?
Von so gespielt
einfach nur.
Einfach nur so gespielt.
Da gibt's
international richtig viele von.
Das kann ich mir nicht angucken, das halt ich nicht aus.
Wen ich auch absolut nicht mag
ist AlexiBexi, ich weiß nicht, ich kenn den
Typ nicht, aber ich
irgendwie find ich die Videos übelst
Crap.
Kommt eigentlich noch ein Battlefield 3 Guide mit
WilliPeteCast?
Boah ey, ich hab von
Felix ewig nichts mehr gehört.
Keine Ahnung.
Vielleicht, irgendwann mal, weiß ich nicht.
Laluco1
abonniert mit Twitch Prime.
Dankeschön, nice.
Hast du noch Kontakte zu GermanLPK?
Nein. Friseur? Ja. Kaboom?
Sehr, sehr unregelmäßig, selten.
WilliPeteCast
zu Battlefield 1 haben wir mal
zwei, drei Nachrichten, also auch nicht, ne.
Max sitzt in der Bahn
und hört die 50 PS.
Ich höre nicht
die 50 PS.
Ich sehe die 500 FPS.
MonkaEye. Was?
Vollviews-Gefühl?
Ein paar Gaming-Booster kaufen.
Hab ich letztens beim Lost gesehen, den
World Wide First Brain
Gaming Brain Booster oder
irgendwie sowas.
Hab ich mal von der Lost dafür Werbung gemacht, ja.
Dann muss das auch was taugen.
Ja, dann wird wahrscheinlich genauso Sellout machen, wie ich früher
bei G2A hole.
DasRatchet hat
5 Abos verschenkt,
Stufe 1. Und zwar an
Centillion, TimoGL,
Salamiprinz,
Samme kann man irgendwie auch
minimal falsch verstehen, Salamiprinz.
An den Stelzo
und an Mirikari. Dankeschön für die ganzen Abos.
Und willkommen an alle, die
die Abos gespendet bekommen haben.
Sehr nice.
Dankeschön.
POG, Alter.
Huge. Massive.
Bleib bei deiner Motivation.
Ich sag doch, ich brauch Energy vom Chat.
Give Energy.
Muss jetzt in jedem Stream
das einzige Gift kriegen.
Ich rede für das Twitch-Zeug, oder?
Das versteht kein Mensch, was ich eigentlich vor mir gebe.
Haha, Flame Haste.
Nee, sogar den haben wir nicht gebannt.
Ach, das ist lustig.
Vom Noob-Special-Video auf den Stream gekommen.
Wollt mal schauen, ob du da bist. Ja, ich bin doch immer noch da.
Kronk. Nee, Kronk find ich gut.
Kronk guck ich persönlich nicht,
weil die Spiele mich nicht ansprechen und Kronk
auch so ultra lahm bei allen Games
ist irgendwie. Aber nee,
Kronk mein ich damit überhaupt nicht.
Ist keiner, der alles gut findet.
Ich erinnere mich noch daran, dass er irgendwann mal
sein SimCity-Let's-Play-Rage quittet hat,
weil das Spiel so gesackt hat.
So Leute wie Kronk mein ich nicht.
Wen gibt's denn da so ultra-ultra-happy-Let's-Play-Typen?
So irgendwie, wie heißt der?
Jacksepticeye
oder irgendwie sowas.
Das kann ich mir alles nicht angucken.
Komm, One vs. One Quickscope.
Aber nur auf Rust.
ConCraft.
Der hat das auch jemanden, den kann ich mir entgeben, ja.
Wenn ich übrigens, wenn ich sage,
kann ich mir nicht geben, heißt das genau das.
Ich kann ihn mir nicht geben.
Das heißt nicht, dass das vom Typ her Spaß sein muss
oder sonst was. Einfach nur, dass ich es mir nicht geben kann.
Vor, als wieder irgendeiner das rumklippt
und irgendwie Beef anfangen will
oder so.
Valuten kenn ich nicht.
Also sagt mir vom Namen aus, hab ich noch nie geguckt.
Max, wenn du willst,
ich bin als Manager noch frei, kannst mich easy buchen,
bekommst gute Placements.
Placements für was? In Overwatch oder wie?
Ach ja, Werbeplacements.
Easy. Auf geht's.
Machen wir, würde ich sagen,
98-2 Split.
Die ganzen deutschen
Minecraft Hipster-Youtubers.
Kenn ich keinen von.
Gibt es den Dehner eigentlich noch?
Der Dehner
ist jetzt Rennfahrer oder sowas, ne?
Verfolge ich nicht, aber
was, wer auch ganz komisch geworden ist
irgendwie ist Unge.
Der React als Unge ist irgendwie das geworden,
was er selbst früher nicht gemacht hat.
Hab ich den Eindruck.
Ich will einfach nur Games spielen
und irgendwie Dinger machen zu
Reaction-Content.
Das hat jeder zu seinem Geschmack, ja.
Du sagst im Noob-Special
was von Programmieren arbeitest du?
Studiere auch gerade Informatik.
Mach mal Ausrufezeichen Beruf.
Da gibt es eine Erklärung zu, was ich gerade auf der Arbeit mache.
Wann kommt dein erster
Gangster-Rap-Track?
Na, ich mach kein Gangster-Rap.
Ich hab gedacht, ich revolutioniere das Ganze ein bisschen.
Ich mach Informatiker-Rap.
Quasi sowas, ich hab's ja vorhin schon gesagt,
so in der Richtung wie
dein Vater ist blau wie das Discord-Logo.
Oder, oder, was könnte man da noch machen?
Ich bin zu unkreativ,
sowas spontan zu machen.
Sowas wie
die Bitches stehen an der Tür
wie bei Philipp am Tor.
Ne, das ergibt keinen Sinn.
Aber habt ihr das verstanden? Witz. Übelst, übelst nice.
Tür und am Tor. Boah, übelst, übelst.
Cringe-Joke, ich weiß.
Das gibt Informatiker-Rap.
Informatiker-Rap machen wir dann.
Wo bestellst du dein China-Kram immer?
AliExpress?
Banggood?
Eigentlich die zwei hauptsächlich.
Painz-Champ.
Ja, das tut weh, ich weiß.
Oh, fuck.
Ich komm im Chat nicht hinterher, Leute.
Mach mal nicht so schnell.
Dankeschön für die Subs.
Dom16
Evils?
Evil?
Evils2222IL?
Ich... language...
x Ragnarok
x RagnasonX
Dankeschön an alle drei für die Subs.
Wo hast du die Sounds fürs Soundboard her?
Das haben wir selbst programmiert.
Onstream sogar.
General Slain
Auch danke für den Sub.
Huge Subscriber
Was ist denn heute los? Heute ist der Wahnsinns, wenn ich weiter so einen krassen
Sellout mache, hier auf dem Stream und öfters
mal auf YouTube poste,
da gibt es ja hier...
Wo ist der Staubsauger? Oh, das hatten wir schon.
Wir haben uns den Staubsauger heute schon angeguckt.
Adopted Anton,
abonniere Twitch Prime. Dankeschön.
Bei wie vielen Subs
bist du mittlerweile? Ich gucke mal nach.
Soll ich mal nachgucken?
Nein, ich habe nicht gefragt.
Sonst scrollt der Chat noch
schneller. Sollte man deiner
Meinung nach, um Fullstack-Web-Developer
zu werden, studiert haben? Nö.
Öhm...
Ocmdk?
Ich hoffe, das stimmt.
Twitch Prime. Dankeschön. Nice.
Ups.
Ja, PC Master Race.
Subscriber.
Take my energy grip. Das ist
falsche Copypasta.
Wieso kann ich die animierten Bilder
nicht im Chat sehen? Du musst das in deinem
Better Twitch TV oder Franker Faces Set
einschalten, dass du animierte E-Mails siehst.
Lohnt sich ein 4K-Bildschirm?
Für Spielen nicht, finde ich.
240 Hertz, größer 4K
für Games.
Fürs Arbeiten schon.
Ich warte ja noch auf
einen passenden Bildschirm für mich.
Ich muss gerade meinen Chat
überscrollen, sonst soll man wieder runterkommen.
Ähm...
Kennst du Stain? Nein.
Wie findest du seinen Stream-Content?
Kenn ich nicht.
Max, geh schlafen.
Ach, das war die Reaction
auf meinen tollen, tollen
Informatiker-Rap-Versuch.
Ja, verstehe.
Am Tor. Ich fand den nicht schlecht.
An der Tür
und Philipp am Tor.
Ja, weil Tor.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man den Typ schreibt, aber man spricht
irgendwie so aus. Max lacht gerade
über 10 Minuten. Ich komm mit dem Chat halt überhaupt nicht
hinterher gerade. Slow-Mode-Chat?
Nee, sowas mach ich nicht.
Das mach ich erst bei 300 Zuschauern plus,
wenn weiter so gespammt wird.
Wenn ihr mit
Twitch-Copy-Pasta anfangen, kann ich euch gleich sagen,
dann kann ich nichts mehr
beantworten aus dem Chat. Das ist dann halt selber schuld.
Dann könnte ich vielleicht YouTube-Comments
wieder beantworten, was ich eigentlich ursprünglich vorhatte.
Der Boss is back, das ist auch nicht schlecht.
Hast du eine extra Tastatur
für die ganzen Animationen im Stream? Nee.
Ich hab so ein Web-Interface.
Sieht so aus.
So sieht das aus.
Und wenn einer was von Java schreibt,
hab ich den hier noch.
Am Start.
Halbschatten. Abonniert Twitch Prime.
Ich muss mal gucken, ob ich nichts vergessen hab in der Zwischenzeit.
Ein Dankeschön-Halbschatten.
Pock.
Ein. Falsch.
Kommt Staubsauger-Stuff noch auf hier?
Klar, klar.
Ich probier das. Ich versuch da Minecraft drauf zum Laufen zu kriegen.
Und wenn Minecraft nicht funktioniert,
wovon ich mal ehrlich gesagt ausgehe,
versuch ich zumindest einen Minecraft-Server
drauf laufen zu lassen, um mich drauf zu connecten.
Ich mein, Minecraft-Server ist für einen Staubsauger
schon krass genug, oder?
Hast du Vikings geschaut?
Ja, die erste, äh,
zwei Staffeln oder so.
Danach hat's mir nicht mehr gefallen.
So. Ich bin mit dem Chat wieder durch.
Ich hab's geschafft.
Ich bin mit dem Chat.
Wie viel RAM hat der Staubsauger?
Gute Frage.
Gucken wir doch mal nach.
Wie viel RAM der Staubsauger hat.
Ich glaub 512 MB RAM hat der Staubsauger.
Also Leute, nur mal angemerkt.
Ich bin gerade per SSH auf meinen Staubsauger.
Ah.
Muss sein.
Staubsauger.
Wie sagt man heute?
Auf meinen Nacken.
Äh.
Ja, 512 MB RAM.
Ganz normal.
Kennt man.
Also 512 MB haben wir.
Auf dem Staubsauger
läuft aktuell gerade ein Ubuntu
14.04 LTS.
Und ich könnte auch ohne Probleme,
ab...
Wart mal, ich probier mal was.
Ab Search Minecraft.
Gibt's das vielleicht sogar schon im Repo drin?
Nee, gibt's da nicht.
Also Staubsauger hat 512 MB.
Aktuell frei.
Also für den Java Minecraft Server
reicht der RAM nicht.
Und der Festplattenspeicher reicht...
Na doch.
Doch, vielleicht brauch ich gar keinen USB Stick.
Ich brauch irgendeinen...
Es gibt bestimmt irgendeinen minimal C Minecraft Server,
der nix kann, aber zumindest
reicht für Connecten.
Den werde ich da drauf installieren und dann spielen wir Minecraft.
Auf dem Staubsauger.
Was muss man nehmen, um auf solche Ideen zu kommen?
Da kommt das eine zum anderen.
C Minecraft Server.
Warum sollst du in C keinen
Minecraft Server programmieren können?
Das ist Netzwerk Zeug.
Für den Minecraft Server ist wichtig, was der Server sendet
und empfängt.
Ob in welcher Programmiersprache der Minecraft Server geschrieben ist,
vollkommen wurscht.
Der Minecraft Server kann auch in...
Fortran programmiert sein oder so.
Vollkommen egal.
Minetest, was ist denn Minetest?
Aha. Ach, gibt's schon für Linux, okay.
Also ich brauch's halt für ARM, weil...
CPU... Ach jo, wir können doch mal gucken,
was für eine CPU im Staubsauger drin ist.
Aber Minecraft ist ja...
Ist doch egal, ob Minecraft Java ist.
Der Client mag Java sein, aber
die Sachen, die er zum Server hin und zurück schickt,
war vollkommen egal, in welcher Sprache der Server selbst ist.
Es gibt Minecraft Server in Go,
es gibt Minecraft Server in C und es gibt Minecraft Server auch in Java.
Aber mei...
Wir gucken, wir gucken mal,
was da... Ach warte, was guck ich denn da?
Ähm... Bin auch falsch.
Also, welche CPU ist
im Staubsauger drinne?
Ein Vierkern ARM 7.
Ja, ARM V7 gibt's garantiert
im Minecraft Server schon fertig kompiliert.
Weil, Minecraft
auf Minecraft Server auf dem
ähm...
Staubsauger Roboter kompilieren
kann man glaub ich vergessen.
Ich will auch ehrlich gesagt keinen Compiler
installieren auf dem Staubsauger.
Ich weiß, klingt abgedreht,
aber ist halt so.
Es ist ein Vierkern, es ist ein Vierkern
ähm...
Vierkern ARM V7
CPU
im Staubsauger drin.
Das sollte für nen billig
Minecraft Server schon reichen.
Ich find's übrigens geil, dass ein Staubsauger
nen Quad Core mittlerweile drin hat, ne?
Und eigentlich musst du auch
Doom auf den Staubsauger... Doom läuft auf
allem. Doom läuft auf allem.
Das ist der S50
Bresk, ja? Ne, Sibaro, ich hab
heut Morgen schon nachgeguckt. Es gibt
Minecraft Server auch in Go und in
und in C.
Sogar schon vorgefertigt für ARM.
Das hätte dir mal wer vor 10 Jahren
sagen müssen, dass du mal Minecraft Server
auf deinem Vierkern Staubsauger
Roboter installieren willst, ja?
Da hätt ich mir vor 4 Jahren gedacht, ich hab's
ja nimmer alle.
Aber das Internet of Shits ist
überall. Gibt auch die
eine, die vom Kühlschrank aus twittert
mittlerweile. Okay, Leute,
ihr kennt's, 22 Uhr.
Ähm,
da muss ich
meistens pennen.
Und das ist auch heute der Fall.
Ich guck jetzt mal kurz, ob's jemand gibt, den ich hosten kann.
Wie hat euch der Stream gefallen
heute? Es war heut ziemlich, äh,
sehr, sehr viel Gelaber. Wir haben
nicht wirklich was gemacht.
Wollen wir ab und zu mal solche, ähm,
YouTube, YouTube
Kommentar... Comment
ähm,
Verantwortungsstreams machen?
Ich glaub, das ist ne gute Idee.
Leider glaub ich keiner on, den ich
hosten konnte. Wer haben wir denn hier?
Den Cyrus
könnte man hosten.
WoW Classic ist zwar nicht meins,
aber ist ein
sehr netter Dude.
Wir hosten einfach gar keinen.
Warum hab ich keinen Emote vor meinem Namen?
Hast du bei mir? Bei mir hast du nen Keks vor'm Name.
Gehst du gerade off? Ja,
in ein paar Minuten.
Ich soll niemand hosten.
Ja, könnt den Cyrus hosten.
Die Sache ist die, es ist WoW Classic
und ich weiß nicht, inwieweit euch WoW Classic
interessiert.
Ich weiß nicht, wie lange er noch spielt.
Und soweit ich auch kein WoW Classic gucke.
Was hältst du von der Unity Media
Übernahme von Vodafone? Ähm,
gutes Thema, ich sag's noch einmal,
ähm, ich hab's
am Anfang gesagt, da waren noch nicht so viele da.
Ähm,
wenn ihr, wenn ihr Themenvorschläge habt,
wo man auch gut nen Video
draus machen könnte, wie zum Beispiel die Unity
Media Übernahme Vodafone, das könnt ich bestimmt ganz
gut in ein Video einbauen.
Und ihr Discord habt, macht mal Ausrufezeichen
Discord. Wir haben einen Discord-Server
und da gibt es auch einen, ich zeig's mal,
da haben wir extra nen Channel für Themenvorschläge
und umso mehr
Themen ich hab, ich mein, ich hab schon mittlerweile jetzt
wieder ne gute Liste an Themen, ja,
aber umso mehr Themenvorschläge
ich hab, umso besser.
Machst du mal wieder IT-Mythen? Ja.
Mach ich. Oh, ich hätt noch,
Leute, weil ich hier grad Axel Foss,
Axel Foss lese,
ich hätt noch einen krassen, äh,
hier,
Rap, äh, ähm,
wie nennt man das überhaupt? Line.
Ja, man könnte irgendwie sowas machen,
wie, ähm, deine Bitches
haben mehr Haare unter den
Achseln wie Axel Foss.
Oh, ist das schlecht, das ist übelst Pain Champ,
Alter, das ist übelst,
das ist Grinch hoch 10.
Hahaha.
Aber ehrlich gesagt, ey,
die meisten Texte, die ich mir da durchlese,
die sind so dermaßen schlecht,
da wär ich auch drauf gekommen.
Haftbefehl ist immer noch, Haftbefehlbeste.
Die Delivery ist auch wichtig,
ja, das kann ich nicht.
Haftbefehlbeste.
Der gibt sich erst gar keine Mühe,
das irgendwie, ähm,
ausgefeilt zu machen.
Der sagt das einfach ohne irgendwas.
Wolltest du dich am Ende nicht noch, hab ich ja mittlerweile schon
gemacht. Hab ich ja schon.
Hab ich ja schon. Thema hab ich ja schon durch.
Ähm,
gut, Leute, also,
ich seh schon, die ersten Leute flüchten.
Ähm, aber jetzt ist ja auch
vorbei. Wie viele Subs hast du
nun? Ich habe, ich gucke mal.
216, übelst
nice, dankeschön für alle Leute, die heute gesubbt
haben.
Richtig, richtig viel, ähm,
richtig viele neue Subs, richtig viele neue Zuschauer.
Wie gesagt, ich hoffe, euch hat's gefallen.
Ähm, 216 Abonnenten,
das heißt, wir haben jetzt noch ein neues Emote.
Ich hab jetzt, glaube,
14 Emote-Slots oder sowas
und sagenhafte
vier Emotes davon
schon verwendet.
Was machst du jetzt mit dem
Big Twitch Money? Hm.
China-Kram kaufen.
Oder an Leute für Bucherzinsen
verleihen.
Demnächst kauf ich mir ein neues Klon.
Shit FPS 2.
Versteuern. Ja, das mach ich,
das mach ich auch, ja.
Twitch-Subs verschenken
mit, mit, äh, Twitch Money.
Hast du feste Zeit zum
Streamen oder immer spontan?
Meistens ab 18 Uhr,
18 Uhr 30. Außer,
die einzig feste Streamzeit,
die ich habe, ist sonntags.
Sonntagmorgens zum
Aufwachen. Das hat eigentlich schon Tradition,
dass wir so rum, dass wir so
9 Uhr 30, 10 Uhr
rum
9 bis
10 Uhr anfangen, einen
Sonntags-Aufwach-Stream zu machen.
Ja, ja, ich bin da mit dem Video, genau.
Okay, Leute.
Ähm.
Outromusik.
Ich hoffe, euch hat's gefallen.
Wir sehen uns beim nächsten Stream. Wir sehen uns
morgen, hoffe ich, spätestens
übermorgen, bei einem neuen
Video.
Und jetzt macht's gut, bis denn. Cu.
Hallo, Jungs und Mädels. Ups. Ha! Falsches
Video.